FOR PUBLIC SAFETY SO WE CAN BE
AN WE HAVE SOME ANXIOUS SENATORS.
ON TIME READY TO GO.
SO WITH THE REST OF PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE PLEASE.
COME TO CHAMBERS
.
WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM LET'S.
BEGIN BY CALLING THE ROLE THIS
IS THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY.
JONES SAWYER HERE.
LACKEY.
POWER QUE HAN [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THE FOLLOWING BILL HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB THREE NINETY FOUR
SKINNER PULLED BY AUTHOR.
ON THE CONSENT PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AJ ARE SEVENTEEN RAMOS MISSING
AND MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN AND GIRLS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB THIRTY SIX
HERTZBERG.
PRE TRIAL RELEASE RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB ONE FOUR ONE
BATES PAROLE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
OFFENSES VALIDATED RISK
ASSESSMENT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ONE SIX FOUR
MCGUIRE INFRACTIONS COMMUNITY
SERVICE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
TWO FIVE SEVEN NIELSEN BYRON
PROHIBITED PERSONS.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB THREE
NINE NINE ATKINS COMMISSION OR
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING.
I DON'T NUMBER SIXTEEN SB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN JONES CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS MENTAL COMPETENCE
EXPERT REPORTS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN
OH ONE JONES BYRON PROHIBITED
PERSONS.
THAT IS PROPOSED CONSENT COUNTER
THESE WONDERFUL.
IT'S BEEN PROBABLY MOVED A
SECOND CALL CENTER CALENDAR
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
BAR QUE HAN BARRICADE HUNT ALLY
DEEP.
I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
CALORIES ADOPTED -- WE WILL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWENTY TWO LEYVA [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
GET [inaudible]
TESTING.
HI GOOD MORNING MORE AIR MOVED
TO BELL.
WELL WELL.
THANK YOU WHAT A GREAT WAY TO
START OFF A TUESDAY MORNING.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO SAY
ANYTHING AT ALL.
GRIEF IS.
POSSIBLE IN BECAUSE WE'RE RICH
AT A GROUP WILL ASK YOU
QUESTIONS OKAY VERY GOOD WELL I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I THINK THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL
CHANGING ONE WORD.
FROM SHOULD TO SHALL WE KNOW
THAT IT'S BEEN PERMISSIVE FOR
MANY YEARS AND THAT HAS NOT
WORKED SO CHANGING ONE WORD THE
WORD SHALL WILL MEAN THAT IT HAS
TO BE DONE RIGHT KIDS HAVE TO BE
TESTED.
WE KNOW THAT DNA SOLVES CRIMES
IT EITHER PUTS THE BAD GUYS AWAY
OR EXONERATES THE GOOD GUYS SO I
WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE I HAVE TWO WONDERFUL
WITNESSES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THEM.
IF NOT.
IT'S THAT YOUR COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIR YES -- IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS YOU'VE THIS
IS THE A O'MALLEY YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES TO DO MELLY VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS COMMITTEE
OKAY.
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO USE ALL FIVE MEN I
I PROMISE I WILL NOT BECAUSE I'M
SURE THAT I COULD NOT SAY IT
BETTER THAN SENATOR LEYVA -- BUT
I WILL SAY THAT THIS IS A MATTER
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS WITH A WITH YOUR
LEGISLATURE.
AND WE HAVE A IT BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN SENATOR
SKINNER WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THAT BILL WAS PASSED AND WOULD
BE WE COULD ONLY GET IT PASSED
BY CALLING LIKE USING THE WORD
SHOULD -- AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS
EVEN WITH THAT SHOULD INSTEAD OF
SHALL THAT THERE WERE MANY
POLICE AGENCIES.
SIX STILL DID NOT SUBMIT KIDS
FROM THEIR EVIDENCE ROOM TO BE
TESTED FOR DNA.
AND SO THIS BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
IT'S TIME THAT WE PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL SURVIVORS AND
PROTECT PEOPLE ALSO WHO HAVE
BEEN ACCUSED BY.
IDENTIFICATION IN THE DNA
EXONERATE SINCE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER EVANS FROM JOYFUL HEART --
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE --
FIRST THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF TESTING RATE
CAPS IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M AMANDA STEVENS -- A BOARD
MEMBER THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION AND A RESIDENT OF
THIS GREAT STATE.
JOYFUL HEART WAS FOUNDED BY LAW
AND ORDER ACTORS AN ADVOCATE
MORISCO HARGETT TODAY AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN WE MADE
ELIMINATING THE RIGHT KICK BACK
LOG OUR TOP ADVOCACY PRIORITY.
JOYFUL HEART IS A PROUD SPONSOR
OF SB TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE TESTING OF ALL RIGHT
KIDS.
IT WILL ALSO MAKE CALIFORNIA A
SAFER.
EVERY NINETY TWO SECONDS SOMEONE
IS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN AMERICA.
AFTER AN ASSAULT LIKELY THE MOST
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE OF THEIR
LIFE.
SOME SURVIVORS GET THEMSELVES TO
A HOSPITAL INSTEAD OF TAKING A
SHOWER.
THE FIRST THING MANY WANT TO DO.
THEY MAY WAIT FOR HOURS BEFORE
THEN GOING THROUGH A FOUR TO SIX
OUR THOROUGH INVASIVE AND
UNCOMFORTABLE PHYSICAL
EXAMINATION TO COLLECT DNA.
THEY EXPECT THAT THE EVIDENCE
WILL BE USED TO IDENTIFY AND
PROSECUTE THE PERPETRATORS.
THE PUBLIC EXPECTS THE SAME.
THEY ARE RIGHT TO THINK SO.
DNA EVIDENCE CONTAINED IN RIGHT
KIDS IS A POWERFUL TOOL TO SOLVE
AND PREVENT CRIME.
WHEN TESTED IT CAN IDENTIFY
UNKNOWN OFFENDERS AND LINK
CRIMES TOGETHER REVEALING SERIAL
RAPIST?
TESTING IN DETROIT OF TEN
THOUSAND KIDS HAS UNCOVERED MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED SERIAL RAPIST
WHO HAVE COMMITTED ALL KINDS OF
CRIMES AND FORTY OTHER STATES
AND DC.
IN CLEVELAND POLICE HAVE
IDENTIFIED MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED SERIAL OFFENDERS OUT OF
FIVE THOUSAND KIDS.
MANY OF THESE OFFENDERS HAVE NOW
BEEN FOUND GUILTY AND TAKEN OFF
THE STREETS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA KEITH ASBURY
JUNIOR OF ANTIOCH SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AT LEAST FIVE WOMEN.
OVER NINE YEARS EVENTUALLY
MURDERING ONE OF HIS VICTIMS.
ACCORDING TO PROSECUTORS AS VERY
KIDNAPPED AND RAPED TWO YOUNG
WOMEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD AND A
NINETEEN YEAR OLD.
THE RAPE KITS COLLECTED FROM
THESE VICTIMS SAT UNTESTED FOR
YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE
ATTEMPTED RAPE OF A FORTY SIX
YEAR OLD WOMAN AND A FEW WEEKS
LATER.
BURGLARIZED A HOME.
RAPING AND MURDERING A THIRTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD STUDENT.
SEVERAL OF THESE CRIMES COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED WITH THE
TIMELY TESTING OF A SINGLE RIGHT
GET BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT ALAMEDA COUNTY DA O'MALLEY
FOR TESTING THE RAPE KITS IN
THESE CASES.
CRIMINALS DON'T STOP UNLESS WE
MAKE THEM STOP.
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA DESPITE
ALL THE PROOF THAT TESTING RIGHT
KIDS AS BEST PRACTICE.
WHETHER OR NOT A RAPE KIT GETS
TESTED DEPENDS ON THE SURVIVORS
ZIP CODE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
JURISDICTION TESTS.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW SAYS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD SEND KIDS
FOR TESTING THIS WAS A WELL
INTENTIONED LAW BUT ISN'T
WORKING.
JOYFUL HEARTS ACCOUNTABILITY
PROJECT HAS ISSUED OPEN RECORDS
REQUESTS TO EIGHT JURISDICTIONS
AND FOUND THAT SIX OUT OF THE
875% ARE EITHER NOT FOLLOWING
THE ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE LAW.
OR HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING HOW
MANY KIDS THEY ARE RECEIVING.
BY PASSING SB TWENTY TWO AND
CHANGING THE SHOULD TO SHALL.
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE DANGEROUS
VIOLENT OFFENDERS OFF THE STREET.
IT WILL DEMONSTRATE A COMMITMENT
TO SURVIVORS TO HELP THEM FIND A
PATH TO HEALING AND JUSTICE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH YOU TO PASS THIS
MUCH NEEDED LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GAIL STORED ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STAFF AN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NAME IN ORGANIZATION.
I'LL HANDLE THAT I'M
REPRESENTING CHANGE FOR JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHECK OF RECORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES NOT
POSITION.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MARCO GEORGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE WITHDREW OUR
OPPOSITION IN THE SENATE AND
MISTAKENLY GOT -- TRANSMITTED TO
THIS COMMITTEE SOME WITH TRYING
IT AGAIN -- WILL CORRECT IT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AS USUAL.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YES.
PERFECT I JUST WANT TO THANK I'M
SENATOR LEYVA AND DM ALLEY FOR
BRINGING THIS IT'S GOING TO GIVE.
IMPORTANT CLOSURE TO SURVIVORS
AND THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
EVERY SINGLE WOMAN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND MAN IS A
VICTIM OF RAPE SHOULD HAVE.
THE RIGHT TO HAVE THIS JUSTICE
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US FOR
AND I HOPE IT MOVE SWIFTLY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- ANY
QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE FEARS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
ME.
WE HAVE A FIRST AND SECOND CALL
THE ROLL.
ON SB TWENTY TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
OUR QUE HAN BAR CAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE F..
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WICKS.
THAT MOTION PAT YEAR YOUR BILL
WITHOUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
NOW WE HAVE MISTER BOB HERTZBERG.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
[inaudible]
ONE NINE TWO POSSE COMITATUS.
I THINK YOU JUST WANT TO SAY
POLICY COMMITTEE.
PASS A COMITATUS PARTIS OF
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY I
KNOW YOU WERE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE AT THAT TIME NOT
DETERMINED.
I DON'T WANT TO BE INSULTED
[inaudible]
BUT BRIEFLY.
THANK YOU MORE BRIEFLY.
WE ALL PASSED THESE LAWS THAT I
HEAR FROM FOLKS THAT I REPRESENT
REYES COMMUNITIES YOU FOLKS UP
THERE ARE WAS PASSED LAWS ALL
THE TIME WHAT YOU TAKE SOME OFF
THE BOOKS.
SO WHY DO WE SCOURED ALL TWENTY
NINE CODES OF THE STATE TO
CALIFORNIA AND FOUND ALL KINDS
OF CRAZY LAWS.
LAWS THE TALKED ABOUT HOW
BIGGEST SUNGLASSES WOMEN CAN
WEAR WHETHER DRIVING CARS
GLASSES THE IDEA IS.
LAWS THE TALK ABOUT OF AND THE
MOVING FORMA.
RIVER WALK DEFORMED WOODEN BARGE
TO A BOAT STEAM BOATS AND ALL
THIS CRAZY STUFF BUT AS I KEPT
DRILL AND DRILL AND EVERYWHERE I
WENT I WAS FOUND A REASON FOR
THE LAW WAS SOMEONE WOULD COME
IN.
AND TELL YOU -- YOU CAN'T REMOVE
THAT FROM THE BOOKS.
AND SO I FIGURED A LAW THAT WAS
ENCOURAGED BY THE SLAVE TRADE IN.
OF IN PUTTING PEOPLE IN JAIL IF
THEY DON'T RESPOND TO ONE OF
POLICE OFF -- A SHERIFF ASKED
THEM TO JOIN THE POSSE COMITATUS
THAT MAYBE THERE WOULD BE NO
OPPOSITION NOW I'M TOLD THAT THE
SHERIFF'S HAD SOME ISSUE ON THIS
BUT WE CALL THEM BACK IN MARCH
NO ONE EVER RESPONDED.
WE HAVEN'T FOUND ANY LAWS ON THE
BOOKS WHICH BEEN USED AND THE
LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS YOU
KNOW.
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE REPEAL IN THIS
LAW THERE ARE A WHOLE HOST OF
LAWS THROUGHOUT OUR CODES.
THAT IN THAT THAT REQUIRE PEOPLE
TO ACT IN GOOD FAITH TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE GOVERNMENT
CODE -- ET WHERE SHERIFF IF IF
THEY ASK YOU THEY CAN ASK YOU
FOR SUPPORT THE IT REFERRING TO
POLICE OFFICERS THE PENAL CODE
PUBLIC OFFICERS TO EXECUTE
PROCESS.
A NOR ALSO IN THE PENAL CODE OF
PEOPLE PEOPLE ARE SOME BELIEVE
ASKED HELP OPEN DISPERSED GOOD
FAITH THE REST ALL OF THOSE
THINGS BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE YOUR
CRIMINAL.
IF YOU DON'T JOIN UP AND WE
FIGURED THIS IS ONE WE THINK WE
CAN TAKE OFF THE BOOKS THE
INTERNS MY TRUSTY YOUNG A IT
LAWYER FROM BERKELEY.
THESE CALL BOTH PAUL BUT IT'S
NOW BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL IS USING
OLD THE A AND HE'D FOUND THIS
LAW TO HELP US DO THIS SO I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THOSE FEW
TIMES WE CAN TAKE A LOT OF THE
BOOKS.
AND IT'S NICE TO SEE A STATTE
THAT IS ALL JUST LINED OUT.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
EIGHT OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KAREN COMMITTEE
GOING BACK US FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF COURSE ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
OUT WE ARE IN.
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
AS WE HAVE BEEN SINCE -- THE
FIRST HOUSE IN THE FIRST
COMMITTEE WHEN IT WAS BROUGHT --
I I I I WOULD NOTE THAT -- WE'RE
UNFAMILIAR WITH CONCERNS WITH
THE STATUTE OTHER THAN IT WAS
CREATED MANY YEARS AGO AND IT
INCLUDES A FINE FOR PEOPLE WHO
DISOBEY IT -- THERE ARE
SITUATIONS IN WHICH A PEACE
OFFICER MIGHT LOOKED PRIVATE
PERSONS FOR ASSISTANCE IN
MATTERS OF EMERGENCY.
ARREST A PUBLIC SAFETY AND WERE
UNCONVINCED THE STATUTE SHOULD
BE REPEALED.
AT AND I JUST.
RESPECTFULLY I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS PROPOSAL WAS
BROUGHT TO US POTENTIAL AN
INFORMAL STATE IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
AND I INDICATED OVER EMAIL TO
THIS TO THE STAFF FOR THAT -- WE
WOULD LIKELY HAVE CONCERNED WITH
IT -- AND SO I JUST I WANT TO
SORT OF CORRECT THAT NOTION THAT --
WE HAVE ENGAGED OR WE HAVE AN
EXPRESS CONCERNS I THINK WE'VE
BEEN FAIRLY CLEAR ABOUT THAT AND
CERTAINLY HAVE A LETTER -- IN
THE RECORD ONCE THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED SO JUST.
JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT FOR
CLARITY -- AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS BUT FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH FIRST OF ALL I MEAN.
CERTAINLY IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S A HIGHLY YOU STATUTE.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW LAST TIME
SOMEBODY WAS ACTUALLY.
CHARGED WITH THIS OFFENSE.
I WOULD I WOULD CHALLENGE
SOMEBODY ON YOUR STAFF TO COME
FORWARD WITH THAT -- BECAUSE IF
YOU CAN.
PROVE TO ME THAT THIS IS A
PROBLEM.
THEN I'LL.
RECONSIDER MY VOTE BUT RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF THE CONSIDERATIONS THAT
ARE BEING.
BENNETT ABOUT FORGET RURAL
COMMUNITIES RURAL COMMUNITIES AT
AND THE ALSO THE THE NATURE OF
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AS MUCH DIFFERENT WHERE THERE'S
A LOT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AVAILABLE.
IN THESE KIND OF CIRCUMSTANCES
GO TO THE ESPECIALLY.
DESERT COMMUNITIES -- IN THE
SOUTH. TO THE NORTH THERE ARE
MANY MANY REMOTE AREAS WHERE --
ASSISTANCE WOULD BE.
NEEDED AND I'D I'D I JUST FIND
THIS TO BE.
INTERESTING NORMALLY WHEN WE
CREATE STATUTES WE HAVE TO SHOW
A PROBLEM BEFORE WE ADDRESS IT
AND I DON'T SEE THIS AS BEING A
PROBLEM.
SEVERAL TROUBLE WITH IT
[inaudible]
YES.
BECOME LIKE A DOVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I TO WILL BE VOTING
FOR THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE OFF AS
MANY OLD IN BAD BILLS AS
POSSIBLE FROM THE BOOKS AND I
THINK RESPECTFUL DISOBEDIENCE.
AND SELF DETERMINATION IS OKAY
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING FOR
THIS BILL AND I WOULD ALSO ASK
THAT -- SENATOR IF HE WOULD
CONSIDER ME AS A CO AUTHOR ON SB
THIRTY SAY ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER GLAD YOU
[inaudible]
COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE AND IF YOU WANT TO
DRESS I WILL NEED TO CONCERNED
YEAH I I A COUPLE OF THINGS YOU
KNOW.
THERE IS A LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
POLICY PURPOSE TO TAKE DEAD
LETTER LAWS OFF THE BOOKS.
THERE IS A PURPOSE THERE IS
INSPIRING CONFIDENCE IN THE
GOVERNMENT AND TO THE PEOPLE WE
REPRESENT THAT SOMETIMES STUFF
IS NO LONGER NECESSARY TO BE A
LAW.
THAT THE SYSTEM ONLY PRODUCES
MORE AND MORE AND MORE LAWS AND
THICKER BOOKS IN THAT PART OF
OUR OBLIGATION IS TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK BACK. TO RECONSIDER AND TO
THINK THAT STUFF THROUGH IN
EXACTLY THE POINT THAT IT HASN'T
BEEN USED TO ME INFORMS EXACTLY
THE REASON WHY IT DOESN'T NEED
TO BE ON THE BOOKS.
BECAUSE IT HASN'T BEEN USED SO
YOU DO SERVE A PURPOSE THE THE
THE INDEED THE SHERIFFS HAVE
BEEN OPPOSING BUT WE ASK THEM IN
MARCH OF ANY INSTANCE WHAT IS
BEEN USED AND WE'VE GOTTEN NO
RESPONSE THE LAST THING WE COULD
FIND WAS IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE AND THE
QUESTION FROM A PUBLIC POLICY
PERSPECTIVE IS WE HAVE ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX LAWS ON THE
BOOKS THAT ALREADY.
REQUIRE A PEOPLE TO BE INVOLVED
BUT THIS DOESN'T JUST SAY A FINE
THIS MAKES IT A MISDEMEANOR YOU
PUT SOMEBODY IN JAIL FOR FAILING
TO DO SO.
THAT TO ME IS DIFFERENT AND THE
LAST ISSUE A RURAL COMMUNITIES
THE EVIDENCE AS WE BEGAN TO LOOK
AT IT IS THAT YOU DON'T NEED TO
PUT SOMEBODY IN JAIL AND TO
FORCE THEM TO CONSCRIPT THEM. TO
HELP YOU BECAUSE GENERALLY IN
SMALLER RURAL COMMUNITIES PEOPLE
KNOW EACH OTHER AND IT'S A
VOLUNTARY ENVIRONMENT WHERE
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO HELP.
THE COMMON GOOD ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OF AS YOU KNOW MISTER
IS BURKE AYE I WORKED ON SOME
BACALL DEVELOPMENT REFORM.
WHERE I LOOK AT ALL THE PLANNING
RULES AND REGULATIONS A LOS
ANGELES HAMMER AND I CUT THAT IN
HALF I REMEMBER HAVING KIND OF
THE SAME ARGUMENT?
WHY DO WE STILL HAVE THESE
PLANNING CODES IN HERE WHEN I
HAD BEEN USED?
NOT AS LONG AS THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS BUT THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS UP.
AND WE START TO ELIMINATE THINGS --
GET A PROBLEM WE HAD WE HAD.
RULES ON THE BOOKS THAT WERE
CREATED BY BUREAUCRATS WITHIN
THE SYSTEM WHO FOUGHT TO KEEP IT
EVEN THOUGH THEY NO LONGER HAD A
PURPOSE.
OR WE COULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING
MUCH EASIER.
AND LESS COMPLICATED -- ULTIMA
REDUCED THE PLANNING BOOK FROM
MAYBE THAT HIGH TO ABOUT HALF
THAT HIGH OFF THE FLOOR -- BUT
IT IT WAS A STRUGGLE SO I
UNDERSTAND AND AND IT'S AND IT'S
GOOD TO START TAKING SOME OF
THESE OUTDATED RULES OFF THE OFF
OF OUR LEGISLATIVE.
CALENDAR SO OUR CHAIRS RECOMMEND
AYE VOTE THANK CIRCLE ROOM.
SB ONE NINETY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING POWER QUE HAN.
POWER QUE HAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
WICKS.
WICKS I THE BILL PASSES.
NOW WE HAVE SENATOR BELL -- ITEM
NUMBER.
THIRTEEN SB TO A FOR JUVENILE
JUSTICE COUNTY SUPPORT OF WARDS
.
EVERY READY CENTER.
THE MORNING EVERYBODY -- MISTER
TERM MEMBERS -- THIS BILL -- IS --
SB -- TWO EIGHTY FOUR KEEP YOU
FELT [inaudible]
KEEP YOU.
CLOSE TO HOME AT NOW OF THIS WAS
A BILL I'VE BEEN TRYING.
TO CONCEPTUALIZE FOR A LONG TIME.
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A TREND
THAT WE ALL.
HAVE SEEN.
AND THE TREND IS THAT -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE --
FACILITY POPULATION HAS GONE
DOWN.
CONSISTENTLY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
THE JUVENILE FACILITIES
POPULATION.
AT THE COUNTIES HAS GONE DOWN.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS SO
WE HAVE A SITUATION.
WHERE WERE NOW CONSIDERING A NEW
DEPARTMENT?
AND SO THAT'S THE CONTEXT WHICH
I'M INTRODUCING THIS BILL MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
NOW IN LOOKING AT THE POPULATION
OF THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
GOOD NOW AVERAGES OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH PER PERSON.
PER YEAR WITH.
OF THAT AMOUNT THE COUNTY'S
CONTRIBUTE 8%.
OR TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YOU.
WITH THE STATE PAYING THE REST
THE TAX BASE ROUTE CHAIRS
SUBSIDIZING -- THE COST OF SO.
WHAT'S HAPPENED AS AS THE
POPULATION.
HAS DROPPED.
THE COST PER PERSON HAS GONE UP.
AND IT'S NOW BECOME A VERY ON
EQUAL -- PROPOSITION ON WHO'S
PAYING.
FOR THE COST OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO THIS BILL INCREASES THE
COUNTY TO BE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR MANY
OF JUST MANY OF NOT ALL BUT TO
SPUR LOCAL REHABILITATION.
COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT AND KEEP
THEM CLOSE TO HOME [inaudible]
AND LIKE IN THE LAST DECADE IT
WAS.
JUST TO GIVE YOU THESE
ASTOUNDING NUMBERS TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE WERE IN OUR FACILITIES
AND STATE FACILITIES.
NOW WE'RE ABOUT.
SEVEN HUNDRED SO IT'S REALLY
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
HOWEVER THIS DID HOWEVER THE
DECLINE IS DUE TO A STEADY
REDUCTION AND YOU CRIME.
CHANGES THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
TO PROMOTE ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION -- WE NEED TO
CONTINUE MAKING THESE CHANGES
FOR YOU.
INVEST IN THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OUR LOCAL
ALTERNATIVES.
CONFINEMENT ON TO YOU.
IN A YOUTH PRISON.
IS DETRIMENTAL TO ONE'S MENTAL
HELP AND FOR YOU.
ESPECIALLY -- SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED TRAUMA.
RELOCATION CREATES CHANGE NOT
INCARCERATIONS STUDIES SHOW
YOUTH ARE EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
AS THEY MOVE FROM ADOLESCENCE TO
ADULTHOOD.
AND HOW WE CARE FOR THEM DURING
THIS YEAR'S WILL SHAPE THE
FUTURE NOW THE GOVERNOR AGREES
THAT THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
ARE NOT APPROPRIATE ENVIRONMENTS
TO ADDRESSING THE USED NEEDS
THAT'S WHY.
HE PROPOSES SHIPPED.
OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT -- FROM
FOR SHIFTING -- DEPARTMENT
JUVENILE JUSTICE OUT OF THE
CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES IN THE BUDGET
SO THAT'S PART OF OUR BUDGET --
THEY WERE CONSIDERING THIS WEEK.
IF WE LOOK AT THEIR CURRENT
POPULATION -- YOU KNOW HOW TO
HOW TO SIT.
WHAT IS THE RESULTS WE GET?
WELL 74% OF THE U..
THAT ARE IN OUR FACILITIES
RECIDIVIST WITHIN THREE YEARS
OTHER WORDS THEY GO BACK INTO
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES IN THREE
YEARS.
IN ORDER TO READ IT THAT THAT'S
THAT'S LIKE A FAILURE RATE
THAT'S PRETTY ASTOUNDINGLY HIGH.
SO WE NEED TO CHANGE THESE
NUMBERS AND ENSURE SUCCESS UPON
RELEASE.
AND THIS BILL CREATES THIS
FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES
TO CRITICALLY CONSIDER ALL
AVAILABLE OPTIONS RATHER THAN
GOING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE FIRST.
SUCH AS CONTRACTING WITH OTHER
COUNTIES.
ARE THOSE THAT DO NOT HAVE
SECURE FACILITIES.
THE BILL AIMS TO PROMOTE LOCAL
REHABILITATION CREATE SUPPORT OF
AND SAFE ENVIRONMENTS AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES IS GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THIS SOME MORE
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
ALL TURN OVER THEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M MORE IN
WASHBURN WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
I IN SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
CALIFORNIA HAS CHARGED COUNTIES
A FEE FOR COMMITTING YOU TO DJJ --
AND WE'VE REVISED SB SEVERAL
TIMES OVER THE YEARS.
SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR WILL SIMPLY
UPDATE THE FEE AMOUNT PLACING IT
ON PAR WITH THE CURRENT COST OF
LOCAL ALTERNATIVES.
AND ENSURING THAT COUNTIES ARE
PAYING CLOSER TO THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
OF THE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER USE -- THAT WE'RE
SPENDING AT DJJ.
MY TEAM HAS DONE EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON CURRENT CONDITIONS
IN THE DJJ FACILITIES AND WE
FOUND THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
OPERATE AS THEY HAVE FOR DECADES.
AS REMOTE PRISON LIKE
INSTITUTIONS THAT EXPOSE YOUTH
TO SERIOUS TRAUMA.
AND WE KNOW THAT YOUTH FARE
BETTER WHEN THEY'RE PLACED IN
SMALLER SETTINGS THAT ARE CLOSE
TO LOVED ONES.
AND YET THE CURRENT FEE FOR
COMMITTING A YOUTH TO DJJ JUST
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
MAKES IT FAR LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
COUNTY TO SEND THE YOUNG PERSON
TO THE STATE.
AND TO KEEP THEM LOCALLY.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN ENSURING THE JURISDICTIONS
ARE DOING THEIR PART TO SUPPORT
YOUTH CLOSER TO HOME.
AND COUNTIES TODAY ARE VERY WELL
POSITIONED TO SERVE MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN LOCAL SETTINGS BECAUSE
ON AVERAGE.
LOCAL FACILITIES ARE OPERATING
AT JUST 30% CAPACITY. 70% EMPTY
WHICH MEANS THEY COULD ABSORB
THE JJ'S POPULATION MORE THAN
THIRTEEN TIMES OVER.
THE STATE IS ALSO ALLOCATING%
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS EACH YEAR
FOR LOCAL SERVICES AND
ALTERNATIVES TO DJJ AND THAT'S
AN AMOUNT THAT INCREASED DESPITE
DECLINES IN THE NUMBER OF YOUTH
INVOLVED IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AN EIGHTEEN COUNTIES HAVE
RECENTLY RECEIVED FUNDS TO
CONSTRUCT OR RENOVATE NEW LOCAL
FACILITIES FUNDS THEY RECEIVED
FROM THE STATE.
SO TO BRING OUR YOUTH BACK HOME
AND ENSURE THAT INNOVATION
CONTINUES LOCALLY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
RIGHT AT THE PERSON [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS ELISA
AMERICA'S AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
SHARE WITH YOU MY VERY OWN
TESTIMONY -- WITH DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE CURRENTLY --
WITH MOTIVATING INDIVIDUAL
LEADERSHIP FOR PUBLIC
ADVANCEMENT.
WHEN I WAS SENT TO DJJ I WAS
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD? ONE THE
CUSTODY OF DJJ HAVE FACED VERY
UNHEALTHY AND POOR CONDITIONING.
PERSONALLY I HAVE A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MY FAMILY.
THEREFORE THEY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
THE ONES THAT I'VE TURN TO FOR
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT.
HOWEVER BEING AT DJJ FALTERED
ARE ONCE THIRTY RELATIONSHIP DUE
TO BEING SEVERAL HOURS AWAY.
EXPENSIVE TRAVEL AND
DISCRIMINATION.
THERE ARE MANY BARRIERS BETWEEN
MY FAMILY AND I WHICH THEY
CREATED A DISTANCE AND
INTERFERENCE WITH OUR BOND IN A
TIME OF CRITICAL NEED.
I'M RECOVERING PARAPLEGIC AND I
WENT TO DJJ NINE MONTHS AFTER
TRAUMATIC INJURY.
I SAY THAT NOT NOT FOR PITY BUT
TO LET YOU GUYS KNOW THAT I NEED
MY FAMILY SUPPORT TO THE HIGHEST
DEGREE.
THE JUSTICES AYE BASEBALL.
BEING IN DJJ PERTAIN TO MY
DISABILITY RIGHTS IMPROPER
MEDICAL CARE AND REHABILITATION
SERVICES THAT WERE NOT EFFECTIVE
IN HELPING ME TO RE INTEGRATE
SMOOTHLY BACK INTO SOCIETY.
THE DJ FAILED TO MEET MY NEEDS
BY NOT PROVIDING NECESSARY IN
VITAL TREATMENT THAT WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BETTERMENT OF
MY OVERALL WELL BEING.
I WAS COMPLETELY ISOLATED FROM
THE OUTSIDE WORLD AND SUCH
REMOTE LOCATION WHICH ONLY
INTENSIFIED MY TIME AT DJJ WHERE
VIOLENCE IS FREQUENT AND STAFF
ABUSE THEIR AUTHORITY.
AND SEEN THAT MY FAMILY WERE
WILLING AND AND WANTED TO BE
THERE AND ACTUALLY ATTEMPTED TO
VISIT ME SAID.
SEVERAL TIMES WERE NEVER ALLOWED
IN ENTRY.
ONLY ADDED TO THE ALREADY
EXISTING BURDEN THAT I CARRIED.
DJJ PREPARED NEEDS. TO GET OUT
AND FALL FACE FIRST.
WHEN I WHEN I WAS RELEASED I WAS
VERY ANXIOUS AND DISCONCERTED?
I DO NOT HAVE ANY CLUE AS AS HOW
TO REBUILD MY LIFE OR MY
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND DUE TO ALL THE PAIN THAT I
HAVE BEEN DELIVERED AND IN HOPES
THAT YOU IN THE FUTURE WHEN I
HAVE TO FACE.
THESE TYPES OF UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I ASK WHOLEHEARTEDLY FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AS BE TWO EIGHTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ENTER MISS FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. TEN YOUR TEARS ON
BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOING BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible] EIGHT CHECK A
BREAKER NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORK CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO MARCH -- CUT WITH
THE LA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH MILK BAR AND
MEET BY THE HOLE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANNA.
MY NAME IS CARLOS MONTOYA.
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME BUT ALSO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIES FOR YOU
THINK COMMUNITY JUSTICE
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LINDA ONE WITH CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HER NAME IN OUR WITH THE CENTER
ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING CHRISTIAN FRANCO
MILPA BUT THE LARGER A. B. Y.
MOC COLLECTED AS WELL IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING JAMES BIRCH ANTI PLEASE
TEAR PROJECT IN SAINT JAMES
INFIRMARY STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ALLEY WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VALERIE WITH IT WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
WHICH IS APPARENT FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND JUSTICE.
YOUTH COLLISION I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
CLOSER GONZALEZ AND STRONG
SUPPORT SURELY PEASANT WILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
THE LAUNCHER FARMER FROM Y. J.
C. AND I STRONGLY AGREE.
THANK YOU SIR.
JACOB JACKSON Y. J. SEEING
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITY WE ALL
LINDA GOMEZ CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
SPECIALIST FOR COMMUNITY
COALITION AND SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER STRICTER TIME DONE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHECKING WITH YOUR FROM YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND A
STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU.
NOTHING OPEN TIME THEN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I RAIL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
TECH COUNTIES.
MEMBERS OF SPEAKERS [inaudible]
SEC [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK.
YES YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
BETWEEN THE THREE OF YOU.
WELL ANYWAY YOU WANT.
I'M HELEN ROUGH THOUSAND FROM
SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
REPRESENTING.
THE TEACHERS AND HEALTH
PERSONALITY JJ AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
IN REALITY THIS BILL WILL LEAD
TO THE CLOSURE OF DJJ AND THE
STATE WITH FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
IN FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS.
AND ONLY SEVEN HUNDRED OF
JUVENILES IN DJJ WE AT WHAT ASK
WHO COULD REPLICATE CURRENT
SPECIALIZED THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
CREATED UNDER FAIR ALL WITHIN
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. FOR
EXAMPLE THE SECULAR SEXUAL
OFFENDERS PROGRAM HAS SIXTY TWO
WORDS FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
IT'S RUN BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CINCINNATI IN A COST MILLIONS
BUT IT HAS GOOD TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS THE PROGRAM RECOGNIZES
THAT MANY OF THE WORDS WERE
THEMSELVES SEXUALLY ABUSED.
SOMETIMES BY PARENTS OR
RELATIVES IN THEIR HOMES.
MAYBE ONLY LA HAS HE NUMBER OF
WORDS TO RUN THEIR OWN PROGRAM.
THERE IS A CON A MI OF SCALE AND
DJJ THAT ALLOWS A PROGRAM TO
OUGHT THESE PROGRAMS OPERATE.
ASK YOURSELF IF IT'S FEASIBLE
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES RUN
THEIR OWN PROGRAMS FOR THIS
POPULATION -- I ASK A JUVENILE
SHORT ONE OF THE JUVENILE.
COURT JUDGES ABOUT THIS IN A
LARGE A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTY AND SHE SAID -- COUNTY
WOULD NOT COMMIT THESE KIND OF
RESOURCES.
IN FACT THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMS ARE
OPERATED BY COUNTIES OR THEIR
THEIR OUTCOMES DESPITE PROVIDING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS.
AND REALIGNMENT WAS PASSED WITH
FEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS MAYBE
THIS IS A GOOD PLACE TO START.
FURTHER THE STATISTICS QUOTED
I'M DJJ ARE WHERE FROM TWENTY
THOUSAND ELEVEN BEFORE TH
TWENTY ELEVEN BEFORE ON THE
CHANGES FROM FAIR ALL WE SEE DJ
JJ AS A TERTIARY FACILITY.
RATHER THAN REPLICATING PROGRAMS
AND FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE
SHOULD STRENGTHEN THE
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE
USED FOR RESOURCES FOR ALL
COUNTY.
SANTA CLARA ANOTHER LARGE
COUNTIES MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO
THIS BUT WHAT ABOUT AMADOR
IMPERIAL.
SISKIYOU SAN LUIS OBISPO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES CAN BE
HIGH AND WE ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MAX.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
G. PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN OPPOSITION
TODAY -- I I WANT TO START WITH
THE FACT THAT WE PROBATION SHE'S
VERY MUCH AGREE WITH THE NOTION
OF KEEPING KIDS LOCALLY AND I
THINK THAT'S EVIDENCED BY.
THE LEADERSHIP OF PROBATION --
ART COUNTY COUNTERPARTS AND AND
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
TO DO THAT OVER SEVERAL SEVERAL --
AT MANY YEARS AND WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT COMMITMENT
THROUGH A 74% REDUCTION -- OF
YOU BEING SENT TO DJJ -- A 60%
DECLINE IN JUVENILE DETENTION IT
IN ITS ENTIRETY -- AND AND DJJ
REALLY DOES REPRESENTS -- NOT
THE FIRST CHOICE FOR FOR
COUNTIES ARE LOCAL COURTS BUT
REALLY FOR THOSE YOUTH THAT
REPRESENT ON THE HIGHEST RISK OF
RE OFFENDING THE HIGHEST NEEDS
OR WHO ARE IN NEED OF
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS THAT.
THAT COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE AN AND
THOSE ARE REALLY THE PRINCIPLES
IN WHICH WE OPERATE UNDER -- IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SLIDING SCALE THAT THIS BILL
KIND OF SEEKS.
TO RE INSTITUTE WAS WAS REALLY
PUT IN PLACE MANY YEARS AGO AT A
TIME WHEN DJJ POPULATION WAS AT
ITS HIGHEST AND SO THE FOCUS WAS
ON HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE TO KEEP.
A MORE YOUTH LOCALLY SB EIGHTY
ONE JUVENILE REALIGNMENT REALLY
SET IN MOTION PROBATION COMING
TO THE TABLE AND SAYING WE WE
WANT TO KEEP THESE KIDS LOCALLY
WE THINK THIS MAKES SENSE.
AND THOSE YOU NOW ARE KEPT
LOCALLY MANY OF WHICH YOU ARE
ACTUALLY IN OUR COMMUNITY BEING
SERVED AND NOT EVEN AND OUR
HALLS.
AND SO REINSTITUTING THIS --
SLIDING SCALE AT A TIME NOW
WHERE DJ POPULATION IS AT ITS
LOWEST -- REALLY DOESN'T FIT
TOGETHER ALL OF THE PIECES AND
DYNAMICS THAT WE KNOW TO BE TRUE
ABOUT HOW THE SYSTEM CURRENTLY
LOOKS -- AND WE ARE VERY MUCH
CONCERNED THAT JUST INCREASING
THE FEE ABSENT ALL OF THESE
OTHER DYNAMICS IS GOING.
TO LOCAL PRESSURES ON THE
FUNDING THAT WE CURRENTLY ARE
USING TO INFUSE THE LOCAL SYSTEM
WHICH IS TO KEEP KIDS OUT OF DJJ
KEEP KIDS OUT OF R. HALLS AND
KEEP THEM IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE
WHERE POSSIBLE AND SO --
DIVERTING FUNDING TO PAY AN
ADDITIONAL COST TO DJ IS GOING
TO HAVE OTHER SYSTEM IMPACTS AND
WE ARE VERY MUCH CONCERNED ABOUT.
NOT WANTING TO MAKE THOSE SHIFTS
AND AND HARM ANY PARTS OF OUR
CUT KIND OF FROM IN PREVENTION
EFFORTS.
AND ULTIMATELY THE HEALTH
WELFARE AND SAFETY OF OUR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY ARE THOSE GUIDING
PRINCIPLES OF OF KIND OF HOW WE
OPERATE IN WHO GOES TO DJJ AND
AND SO WERE CERTAINLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACTS THAT THIS BILL
WILL HAVE WE ASK FOR YOUR NEW
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA IT
HERE BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING FOURTEEN OF THE
LARGEST COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE
RURAL COUNTY -- REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THIRTY SIX OF THE THE SMALLER IN
RURAL COUNTIES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION I WILL ALIGN MYSELF
LARGELY WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA --
AND WOULD JUST MAKE TWO
ADDITIONAL POINTS FROM THE BROAD
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE
ALWAYS HAD THE VIEW.
THAT THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS INDEED THAT A SYSTEM WITH A
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES SANCTIONS
INTERVENTION PREVENTION -- A
PROGRAMS WITH THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE YOUTH BEING SERVED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- WE DO VIEW -- AS
MS SANCHEZ INDICATED -- AND
APPRECIATE THE BENEFITS OF
KEEPING KIDS LOCALLY IN IN
ABSOLUTELY EVERY INSTANCE THAT
WE CAN.
BUT THERE IS -- AT AT THE AT THE
DEEP END AT THE THE HIGH NEED
AND OF THE CONTINUING WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE HAS A
ROLE IN PROVIDING SERVICES AND
SPECIALIZED TREATMENT THAT
COUNTIES.
DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
MANAGE LOCALLY IN EVERY INSTANCE --
SO WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THE STATEMAINTAIN A PRESENCE
REGARDLESS OF WHERE DJJ MAY
EXIST IN IN THE STATE SYSTEM WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THE STATE HAS A
ROLE IN PROVIDING SERVICES TO
THOSE A YOUTH WHO HAVE THE
HIGHEST NEEDS -- AND SECONDARILY --
THERE ARE FISCAL IMPACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL THAT IS
NOT THE THE MAIN POINT THAT
WE'RE MAKING TODAY -- BUT WE I
THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
INCREASING THE FEE WILL HAVE
POLICY IMPACTS AS WELL WE WILL
BE TAKING RESOURCES FROM
COUNTIES THAT WERE CURRENTLY
INVESTING IN KEEPING THE KIDS
LOCALLY WE WILL HAVE TO TURN
AROUND AND USE THOSE RESOURCES.
TO PAY FOR THE HIGHER FEE AND
FOR THOSE REASONS ON BEHALF OF
YOU SEE SEE AN RC RC WE REGRET
THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
JESSICA ELEVEN TEN THE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION.
RG RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOW PARTISAN CENTER THAT WE
MISSED THE ME TO THIS BUT THIS
CAN GO FROM THE JUSTICE
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT HONORED
TO BE COSPONSORS?
WE NOW THE RESOURCES AND THE
KNOWLEDGE TO BUILD LOCAL
ALTERNATIVES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MILLER LOOKS UP IN
WHAT YOU JUST AS COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
AND GROWTH POLICIES WE ALSO
MESSED KAELIN DEAN ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY
LINK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PLAN TO DO OVER THE DO JUSTICE
COALITION PUCKLE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR QUIRK --
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND
I'LL MOVE IT IN A MOMENT BUT
FIRST I'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
TO THE OPPOSITION -- THIS BILL
DID GET THIRTY VOTES IN THE
SENATE.
I DO NOT THINK THAT THE AUTHOR
PLANS TO SHUT DOWN DJJ I THINK
THE COMMENTS ABOUT CERTAIN KIDS
BEING SERVED BASS.
THEY'RE PROBABLY MAKES SENSE.
BUT WHAT I ALSO SEE IS A GREAT
DISPARITY.
ALAMEDA COUNTY HAS THE CITY OF
OAKLAND KNOWN FOR UNFORTUNATELY
HAVING A LOT OF YOUTH VIOLENCE.
YES.
WELL IT'S 50% LARGER THAN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY -- WHICH HAS MUCH
LESS OF AN URBAN -- USE OF
VIOLENCE PROBLEM THEY SAID TWICE
AS MANY PEOPLE TO D. J. J..
ARM YOU LOOK AT IT AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE YOU WILL
SEE COUNTIES THAT STICK OUT.
AS SENDING MANY MORE PEOPLE.
NOW IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT THIS
SOLUTION I WOULD SUGGEST YOU
SUGGEST ANOTHER OR IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THE MONEY THAT IT
COSTS.
TO SMALLER COUNTIES THAT YOU
SUGGEST -- SOME REDISTRIBUTION
OF BUT I WOULD DEFINITELY LOOK
FOR SOME SORT OF COMPROMISE ON
THIS AGAIN I DO THINK D. J. J.
MAKE SENSE. FOR MANY KIDS I'M
JUST CONCERNED WHEN I SEE THIS
DISPARITY.
THAT NOT ALL THE KIDS WHO SHOULD
BE SENT THERE ARE SENT THERE AND
THAT I'M WORRIED THAT SOME OF
THOSE SHOULD BE KEPT LOCALLY.
OF FOR THAT REASON AGAIN I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I MOVED
TO BELL.
ANY OTHER CON JUST BARKING.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR COMMENTS
DR THE COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE IS
YOU MENTIONED THE RECIDIVISM
RATE AT THE STATE FACILITIES YOU
KNOW WHAT THE COMPARABLE
RECIDIVISM RATE IS AT THE LOCAL
FACILITIES.
SAID THAT DATA ISN'T COLLECTED
OKAY.
HERE THAT A LOT FOR THE COUNTIES.
I'M SO I GUESS I WOULD ASK WHAT
YOUR COMMENT IS TO THE
SPECIALIZED NEEDS.
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO BRING SAT
I MEAN I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IN ALL PRISON POPULATION STAYING
CLOSER TO HOME IS BETTER FOR THE
PRISONERS AND FOR RECIDIVISM
RATES -- BUT THAT BEING SAID I
THINK AS WE'VE MOVED TO MORE OF
A SYSTEM THAT HOLDS PEOPLE
COUNTIES WE ALSO SEE.
SOME PLACES LAST PROGRAMMING
RIGHT AND THAT IN SOME CASES
THERE ARE IT ISN'T LEADING
NECESSARILY TO BETTER RESULTS IN
HERE WE DON'T HAVE ANY DATA TO
WHETHER THAT'S TRUE OR NOT.
AND SO I GUESS I WOULD ASK WHAT.
IN THE BILL YOU USE AND SORT OF
WHAT I WOULD THINK IS A ROUGH --
CORRELATOR WITH THE TYPE OF
CRIME COMMITTED SEVEN YEARS.
VERSES I'M MORE SPECIALIZED
DETERMINANT OF WHETHER SOMEONE
NEEDS ONE OF THE SPECIALIZED
PROGRAMS AND SO I WOULD ASK HER
WHAT YOUR RESPONSES AND WHY.
THE DECISION WASN'T MADE.
TO TO REALLY TAYLOR THIS BILL SO
THAT THOSE WHO NEED THE
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS THAT THE
STATE IS PROVIDING CAN CONTINUE
TO BE SENT AND WE ARE KEEPING
THE PEOPLE CLOSE TO HOME WHO
NEED IT.
WELL JUST YOU KNOW -- KIND OF
GIVE YOU YOU ASKED WHAT MY
REASONS WORK I THINK I THINK YES
THEY ARE.
THE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
FOR THOSE WHICH HAVE LESS THE
FEARS SERIOUS CRIMES.
AND OR COMMITTED A CRIME UNDER.
SIXTEEN AND THEN DOES IT HAVE
THE MORE SERIOUS CRIMES WE
RECOGNIZE.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE.
THAT WE LEFT AT THE TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THOSE PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO COME TO THE
FACILITY IF A COUNTY WANTED TO
SEND THE LESSER.
OFFENDING -- GROUP TO THE
FACILITY THEY CAN WE'RE NOT
RESTRICTING THEM IN ANY WAY --
THEY JUST HAVE TO PAY WHAT WE
CONSIDER TO BE.
A FAIR WHICH IS LESS THAN HALF
OF THE COST.
LESS THAN HALF THE COST.
AND SINCE I'M ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
IN THE SENATE -- I'M THE ONE
THAT LOOKS AT THE BUDGET.
AND I OBSERVED THAT WE GET OF
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
COUNTY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
OKAY SO WEAK WE GIVE THEM GIVE
BLOCK GRANTS TO THE JUSTICE
BROWN -- WE GIVE THEM THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- FOR
THEIR FACILITIES WHICH ARE YOU
KNOW UNDER CONSTRUCTION AT THIS
TIME.
AND THEY STILL HAVE --
FACILITIES THAT ARE ONLY A THIRD
FULL.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
THERE SERVE THIS REALIGNMENT
TAKING PLACE WERE MOVING OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH'S --
HUMAN SERVICES -- WERE FOCUSED
ON MAY.
LOOK AT OUR FACILITIES IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AND MAYBE
READJUSTING OUR FACILITIES OVER
TIME -- YOU MIGHT SEE.
MAYBE SMALLER FACILITIES
OPERATED BY THE STATE YOU MIGHT
SEE.
CONTRACTS WITH CERTAIN COUNTIES
TO OPERATE.
WHAT I CALL THE INTERMEDIATE
LEVEL TYPE OF FACILITIES THAT
OTHER COUNTIES COULD SEND?
YOUNG PEOPLE -- TO THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS WILL HAPPEN -- I THINK
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM'S
NOT GOING TO STAY THE SAME IT'S
GOING TO CHANGE.
OF WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO OPERATE
THIS FACILITIES.
ONLY WITH A THIRD OF THE PEOPLE
AND AT THREE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IT'S
MONEY THAT.
WE HOPE WILL SPENT WE CAN SPEND
IT ON THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
ANOTHER WAY THAT WILL REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
SO I THINK THERE'S THIS
REALIGNMENT TAKING PLACE.
RIGHT NOW OF THIS BILL DOESN'T
SOLVE ALL THOSE REALIGNMENT
ISSUES.
THIS COMMITTEE AND AND OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND OTHER
PEOPLE SHOULD BE THE GOVERNOR
SHOULD BE -- FOCUSED ON THIS
SUBJECT OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS SO BIG PITCHER.
ISSUE BUT BUT FOR OUR BILL -- WE
THINK THIS IS THE WAY.
TO MAYBE SIGNIFY THAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
SAYS RIGHT NOW IS NOT WORKING.
FOR ANYBODY.
SO THE OFFENSE THAT THE
OPPOSITION CITED WAS YOUTH SEX
OFFENDERS WOULD THEY FALL AND I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T KNOWWHAT THE
SENTENCE ON THAT IS WOULD THEY
FALL UNDER THE SEVEN YEARS ARE
OVER THE SEVEN YEARS.
DOING NOW ANYBODY.
YEAH THAT'S THE SEVEN YEAR
AGGREGATES -- SENTENCE SO IT
WILL BE A CASE BY CASE BASIS --
BUT I MEAN I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ALSO TO POINT OUT THAT
THE THE THERE IS A PROGRAM FOR
YOU FOR SEX OFFENSES AT DJJ WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT
PROGRAM AND THE AT TREATMENT OF
USE THAT ARE COMING INTO THE
FACILITIES WITH SEX OFFENSES AT
DJJ.
SO I GUESS I WOULD URGE AND WE
HEAR THIS A LOT FROM THE WAY
WE'VE MOVED IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
IS WE DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA ON
WHAT IS WORKING AND WHAT IS NOT
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
AND I THINK THAT.
I URGE ALL OF US TO BE MAKING
MORE INFORMED DECISIONS WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT IF
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING IF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE -- ACIDITY TING
OR NOT AND THAT WE SHOULD BE
MAKING DATA DRIVEN INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT IS BEST FOR
OUR YOUTH AND HOW TO TREAT THEM.
AND WE KNOW THE BEING CLOSE TO
HOME IS BEST FOR YOU BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THE GETTING THE TREATMENT
THEY NEED IS BEST FOR YOU.
AND SO HOW DO WE FIND OUT WHAT
IS WORKING AND CONTINUE THAT AND
NOT JUST MAKE DECISIONS BECAUSE
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEBEST IDEA SO
I WOULD -- JUST TO HAVE TO GET
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION AND TRY
TO MAKE A DECISION AND IF THAT
IS A YOUTH POPULATION THAT IS
BEING BETTER SERVED IN THOSE
PLACES THEN WE WE CATER THE BILL
TO ENSURE THOSE PEOPLE GET THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MARKET OF THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS WELL I
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW THAT I
THINK THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DISMANTLE D. J. J..
BUT IF THAT WERE THE CASE I
WOULD BE OKAY WITH THAT -- TOO I
THINK THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FACILITIES THAT ARE NOT
FULL.
WHAT YOU END UP WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS?
YOU EITHER HAVE THE STATE
TURNING INTO A PROPERTY MANAGER --
OPERATING FACILITIES OR YOU HAVE
A STATE LOOKING TO FILL ITS
VACANCY RATE.
AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT INTERESTED
IN HAVING THE PENDULUM SWING
BACK SO THAT WE CAN FIND WAYS TO
FILL THOSE SLOTS BECAUSE WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO PROVE.
THAT THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP IN PLACE.
WE MAY NOT HAVE THE ANSWERS TO
EVERY QUESTION.
AND ANSWERS THAT ARE PERFECT BUT
THAT'S CALLED LIFE AND IT'S ALSO
CALLED EVOLUTION AND I THINK
WHAT THIS BILL IS SAYING IS THAT
WE HAVE DONE THIS FOR A TIME.
AND IT'S PROVEN NOT TO BE
EFFECTIVE I ALSO THINK.
THAT HAVING USED THESE ARE YOUTH
PRISONS ESSENTIALLY.
ISOLATED FROM THEIR COMMUNITY
FROM THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
IS NOT HELPFUL MANY OF US ARE
PARENTS AND WE'RE CERTAINLY NOT
INTERESTED IN SENDING OUR KIDS
VERY LONG DISTANCES FOR VERY
LONG PERIODS OF TIME WITHOUT ANY
HELP OR WITHOUT ANY --
VISITATION FROM US OUR COUNCIL.
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
A NUMBER.
OF ROBUST.
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WHO CAN
PROBABLY HANDLE THE SPECIALIZED
NEEDS THAT A NUMBER OF THESE
YOUTH MEET.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE GO BACK TO THE COMMUNITIES.
WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FROM AND
SAY HOW DO WE INTEGRATE OF THOSE
SERVICES AND THOSE MENTORS INTO
THE LIVES OF THESE YOUNG FOLKS
WHILE WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY
REHABILITATE?
RATHER THAN AND FIND WAYS TO
SHIFT THEM CONTINUALLY INTO A
STATE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENT TO
THE QUESTION.
YOU MAY CLOSE SENATE BILL
SHARMAN WE HAVE WE HAVE FOUR
FACILITIES -- THE USED TO HANG
OUT HANDLE UP TO TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
OF NOW THERE ARE.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND WE'RE RUNNING
THE FOR FACILITIES AS YOU SAID
AS A PROPERTY MANAGEMENT.
AND AND THE SYSTEM'S GOING TO
CHANGE WHEN IT GOES OVER TO THE
OTHER DEPARTMENT.
SO -- I THINK I THINK -- WE ALL
KNOW.
IN CRIMINAL JUST STARTING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THAT BRINGING KIDS CLOSER TO
THEIR HOME TO THOSE RESOURCES.
THERE NEAR WHERE THEY LIVE HERE
FAMILIES.
IS IS THE PROPER WAY. TO HANDLE
KIDS THAT HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES
AND IF WE EVER HOPE TO
REHABILITATE THEM.
AND PREVENT THE RICH RECIDIVISM
WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY I INTRODUCED THIS
BILL AND I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I'M.
GOING TO SUPPORT IS I THINK PART
OF PROBLEM IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT NEW IT IS -- I'M GOING TO
NORWAY. TO LOOK AT HOW THEY
IMPRISON.
PEOPLE THERE.
THEY'RE NOT GRAY THEY'RE NOT
CEMENT THE NOT BARS -- LOT OF
LOOK LIKE DORMS AND THEY HAVE A
HUGE -- RATE WHERE PEOPLE DO NOT
RECEIVE A THEY TREAT THEIR THEIR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS MUCH
DIFFERENT.
I THINK THE WAY WE START IS TO
START WITH OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
THE THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO
HANDLE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
NOT ALREADY CHANGED THE
FACILITIES THE WAY THEY LOOK.
BUT I WANT THIS I'VE NEVER BEEN
A BIG FAN AND I PROBABLY GET
SOME GROUNDS OF OF EVIDENCE
BASED I'VE BEEN A FAN OF RETURN
ON INVESTMENT.
WHICH MEANS YOU PROVE THAT
YOU'RE PROGRAMS WORK AND YOU
PROVE THAT YOU GET MONEY BACK.
TO THE STATE AND MAKE IT
PROFITABLE.
YOU MAKE IT SO THAT IT MAKES
SENSE TO MAKE IT SO THAT PEOPLE
GET BACK HOME. TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR FRIENDS AND THEIR
SCHOOLS AND THEY DON'T STAY
WITHIN THAT PRISON INDUSTRIAL
SYSTEM.
AND JUST STAY IN IT FOREVER AND
THAT'S WHAT I CALL RETURN ON
INVESTMENT.
EVIDENCE BASE IS I CAN PROVE IT.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO AUDIT.
RETURN ON INVESTMENT YOU HAVE TO
AUDIT AND WHEN IT DOESN'T WORK
YOU NEED TO GET RID OF IT.
WHEN IT DOES WORK YOU NEED TO
GET MORE MONEY TO IT AND USUALLY
EXPANDED AND YOU MAKE MAKE SURE
IT IS ROBUST AND SO I THINK
THAT'S PART A PROBLEM WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO?
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
FULLY SCOPED OUT ON THE ULTIMATE --
GOAL FOR TODAY JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM HOPEFULLY WE CALL IT.
NOT AT RISK BUT AT BEEN A
PROMISE SYSTEM BECAUSE THERE'S A
PROMISE OF THE USE OF AMERICA
THAT WE'RE REALLY FIGHTING.
FOR WITH THAT [inaudible]
CALDERON.
ON SB TWO EIGHTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BAR QUE HAN BAR KAY
AND I DEEP.
DEEP NO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THE BILL PASSES
THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
MISTER HILL AND EMMA TAKE
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND I'M A
PRESENT MY BILL AFTER THAT EIJI
OURS. NINETY ONE SECOND CHANCES
MONTH RIGHT AFTER CENTER HILL
PRESENTS HIS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- IN MEMBERS SB TWO
TWENTY WILL STRENGTHEN SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS AT FIRE ARMS
RETAILERS TO HELP PREVENT FIRING
THEFT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE APPROVED SP FOUR SIXTY
FOR A BROADER VERSION OF THIS
POLICY.
THESE BILLS WERE THE WINNER OF
MY THERE OUGHT TO BE A LAW
CONTEST SUBMITTED BY A
CONSTITUENT.
AFTER BURGLARS USED A CAR TO RAM
INTO A GUN STORE IN MY DISTRICT.
THE ROBBERS BROKE INTO BROKE IN
ON A SUNDAY MORNING INSTALLED AN
UNDISCLOSED NUMBER OF GUNS LEFT
IN THEIR CLASS IN THEIR GLASS
DISPLAY CASES.
THIS WAS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT IN.
IN THESE TYPES OF BURGLARIES ARE
ON THE RISE THE A TF TOLD MY
OFFICE THAT AT LEAST ELEVEN
OTHER SIMILAR SMASH AND GRAB
ROBBERIES TOOK PLACE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN INCLUDING.
ANOTHER IN MY DISTRICT SIMILAR
SMASH AND GRAB FIREARM DEATHS
HAVE OCCURRED MORE RECENTLY IN
LOOMIS FAIRFIELD STOCKTON AND
DIXON.
BETWEEN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN GUN STORE
BURGLARIES INCREASED BY 71% IN
CALIFORNIA IN OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED GUNS WERE STOLEN.
IT'S WELL ESTABLISHED THAT
STOLEN GUNS ARE OFTEN USED TO
COMMIT CRIMES SEVERAL ROBBERIES
HAVE INVOLVED THE USE OF A CAR
AS A BATTERING RAM IN MANY
INSTANCES THE GUNS WERE LEFT
UNSECURED OVERNIGHT.
IN THEIR DISPLAY CASES. TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AS BE TO
TWENTY UPDATES THE CURRENT
SECURITY STANDARDS FOR GUN
STORAGE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I HOSTED A
SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH GUNS
STORE OWNERS. TO SEE IF WE CAN
MAKE THE BILL MORE FLEXIBLE.
AS A RESULT WE EXPANDED THE
NUMBER OF SECURITY OPTIONS FROM.
TWO TO SIX PROVIDING IMPROVE
COMPLIANCE OPPORTUNITY
SPECIFICALLY EACH GUN STORE MUST
COMPLY WITH ONE OF THE FOLLOWING
SIX SECURITY OPTIONS.
WITHIN WHEN STORING THEIR GUNS
WHILE THE STORE IS CLOSED.
LOCK THE GUNS IN THE SAFE LOCK
THEM WITH A STEEL CABLE AND
INSTALL BOLLARD IN FRONT OF THE
STORE OR LOCKED THE GUNS BEHIND
STEEL ROLL DOWN DOORS OR GATES
OR LOCK THE GUN GENERAL GUN RACK.
WITH A LOCKING STEEL BAR LOCKED
THE GUNS IN A WINDOWLESS SECURE
ROOM OR INSTALL STEEL ROLL DOWN
DOORS ON ALL DOORS AND FLOOR TO
CEILING WINDOWS OR FINALLY.
LOCKED THE GUNS IN A GUN CABINET
MADE WITH STEEL AND
POLYCARBONATE SHEETS WE ALSO
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION BY SIX
MONTHS TO GIVE TIME FOR STORES
TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE.
IT'S APPARENT FROM MY MEETINGS
AT MANY GUN STORES ARE ALREADY
IN COMPLIANCE WITH AT LEAST ONE
OF THESE REQUIREMENTS AND AS A
RESULT.
I THINK THIS BILL WILL IMPACT A
SMALL NUMBER OF STORES.
WELL I BELIEVE WELL I BELIEVE WE
BROUGHT GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO
THE BILL THERE ARE WERE A FEW
ISSUES WE COULDN'T RESOLVE. FOR
EXAMPLE IT WAS REQUESTED THAT I
ELIMINATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EXISTING AUTHORITY. TO ADOPT
THEIR OWN REGULATIONS.
HOWEVER THIS LOCAL AUTHORITY HAS
BEEN ON THE BOOKS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE IT WAS
NEVER THE INTENT OF THIS BILL TO
UNDERMINE THAT LOCAL CONTROL
OF THE S. B. TWO TWENTY PUTS
FORWARD A REASONABLE AND
FLEXIBLE SOLUTION TO A REAL
PROBLEM ADDITION WHEN ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT REMAIN I
I HAVE -- A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YEAH THE MORNING AMANDA
WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE.
AT OUR NEW NAME DOWN -- WE ARE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'D
LIKE TO MAKE THE POINT THAT
EVERY FIREARM STARTS OUT AS A
LEGAL GUN.
AND AT SOME POINT OUR STARTS HAS
A LEGAL GUN AND MANY HOW UP WHAT
ARE BECOME ILLEGAL GUNS --
OBVIOUSLY FIND SOME WAY TO GO
INTO THE INTO THE BLACK MARKER
BECOME LEGAL IN THE CHAIN OF
CUSTODY FROM.
MANUFACTURER DISTRIBUTOR DEALER
TO TRAFFICKER OR A THIEF -- AND
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE DATA --
CLEARLY ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
GUNS GET INTO THE BLACK MARKET
AND MAY ALTMAN BEING USED IN
pFIREARM DEALERS AND OP WHEN ONE
CONSIDERS THE NUMBER OF GUNS
THAT ARE STORED IN THE FIREARMS
DEALER.
THE POTENTIAL FOR MANY FIRES THE
STOLEN AT ONE TIME -- IS VERY
ALARMING AND CERTAINLY A THREAT
TO PUBLIC SAFETY AS YOU'VE HEARD
THAT THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE IN
THESE INCIDENTS.
I IN RECENT YEARS MY MY
STATISTIC WITH SEVENTY TWO POINT
53% INCREASE HERE'S A SEVENTY
ONE NONE THE LESS THERE HAS BEEN
AN INCREASE IN IT'S OF GRAVE
CONCERN.
IN MY OWN COMMUNITY IN NEVADA
COUNTY IN GRASS VALLEY THERE WAS
A SO CALLED CRASH AND GRAB INTO
A GUN STORE THAT'S RIGHT ON THE
EDGE OF A BIG NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND BELIEVE ME THIS WAS VERY
TRAUMATIC FOR ALL THE RESIDENCES
RESIDENTS ARE IN THAT AREA OF
GRASS VALLEY -- THIS BILL HAS
BEEN BEFORE YOU BEFORE YOU HAVE
PASSED IT I KNOW THAT THE
SENATOR LAST TIME AROUND AUG
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
WORKING WITH -- DEALERS. TO FIND
SOLUTIONS THAT WERE WORKABLE --
THE STORAGE SOLUTIONS THE
CHOICES THAT ARE REQUIRED IN
THIS BILL WOULD BE ONE TIME
EXPENSES FOR DEALERS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE THAT POINT -- AND WE FIND
THIS -- CONSIDER THIS IMPORTANT
WAY TO PREVENT GUNS FROM GETTING
INTO THE LEGAL MARKET AND
PERHAPS BEING USING CRIME AND
CAUSING FIREARM INJURY AND DEATH
THEREFORE WE URGE YOU TO ONCE
AGAIN PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY WITH.
I HAVE A QUICK BAY AREA STERN
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- CAPPING
LET'S REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA --
FIREARMS MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS SO I FIRST WANT TO SAY
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR HALL I
HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR HIM
AND HE DID WORK WITH US IN GOOD
FAITH ON THIS BILL.
IN THE PAST HOWEVER WE DO
CONTINUE TO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL -- THIS
DOES PROVIDE MORE THAN ONE WAY
TO COMPLY.
BUT AGAIN THE SECURITY MEASURES
THAT ARE OFFERED OF FOR
RETAILERS THAT HAVE
SOPHISTICATED AN INTRINSIC PLANS
ALREADY IN PLACE THIS IS
CUMBERSOME AND AND NOT WORKABLE.
FOR EXAMPLE BASS PRO SHOP DOES
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THEY'VE
MENTIONED FOR EXAMPLE THAT THEIR
THEIR STORE IS ON FROM FLOOR
LEVEL AND LIKE BALLARD'S DON'T
WORK SO MANY OF THE OPTIONS
OFFERED DON'T WORK FOR THEM.
BUT THEY HAVE OTHER SECURITY
MEASURES IN PLACE.
THEY'RE ALSO LOCAL ON
JURISDICTIONS THAT LIMIT VARIOUS
CHANGES.
THAT ARE BEING RECOMMENDED AS
THE OPTIONS IN THE BILL DUE TO
LOCAL ORDINANCES SUCH AS
BALLARD'S DEPENDING ON WHERE THE
STORE IS LOCATED.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A DAHLE
REQUIREMENT I UNDERSTAND WHAT --
CENTERVILLE SAYING ABOUT THE
LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE HOWEVER IF
YOU HAVE THE STATE.
OF LAW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO PUT
INTO EFFECT HERE IN CONFLICT
WITH THE LOCAL REGULATION -- THE
RETAILER NEEDS A CLEAR PATHWAY
TO KNOW HOW TO COMPLY BECAUSE
THEY TECHNICALLY BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH ONE OF THE
OTHERS -- WITH THE BILL ONLY
PROVIDES A LICENSEE AN EXCEPTION
IN THE AUTHORITY GRANTED IF --
THEY SEEK ONE IT ISN'T A SHALL
IT'S A MAY AND THEY SHOULD BE
GIVEN THAT EXEMPTION IF THEY
HAVE NO WAY TO COMPLY -- THIS
GREATLY INCREASES THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS IN THE STATE
WITHOUT ANY MAJOR BENEFITS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THESE ARE VALUABLE PRODUCTS TO
THE BUSINESS AND THEY WOULD
INCUR INSURANCE A PRODUCT LOSSES
IF THEY HAVE STEPS.
THEY HAVE A STAKE IN PROTECTING
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEY COULD
LOSE THEIR LICENSE -- UNDER
THESE CONDITIONS WHILE DATA WAS
DISCUSSED FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN A AS A
DRIVER FOR THE BILL THE MOST
CURRENT FBI SEMI ANNUAL.
CRIME REPORT SHOWS A DECREASE OF
FOUR POINT 3% VIOLENT CRIME
RATES WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE
SMASHING GRABS.
LASTLY THE INDUSTRY HAS AN
AGGRESSIVE PROGRAM FOR RETAILERS
AND US ABOUT HAS A VIDEO.
THEY DO -- THEY HAVE SECURITY
TEAMS ARE AVAILABLE TO RETAILERS
TO GO IN AND DO COMPLIANCE
AUDITS AND HELP THEM WITH
SECURITY MEASURES.
THEY WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES -- ON THESE PROGRAMS SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF ACTIVITIES
ALREADY UNDER WAY.
WE THINK WELL SB TWO TWENTY AS
WELL INTENTIONED IT WILL CAUSE
UNDUE CONFUSION CHAOS AND COST
TO BUSINESSES WITHOUT ANY
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN THIS CASE THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND WHAT I WANT TO
DO IS I WANT TO BRING THIS THIS
PROBLEM.
INTO REAL PERSPECTIVE WITH THE
WITH THE REAL NUMBERS AT A
REPORT.
BY THE OF YOUR WALK ALL TOBACCO
AND FIREARMS REGARDING
SPECIFICALLY THIS ISSUE.
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE HAVE BEEN
OVER A MILLION GUNS SOLD. TO THE
PUBLIC THROUGH GUN DEALERS.
NOW THOSE OF THOSE SOLD THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE THE MILLIONS
THAT ARE STILL IN INVENTORY.
AND OUT OF THAT THREE YEARS AGO.
DO THE BURGLARIES WHERE THEY
BROKE INTO GUN STORES OR STOLE
GUNS FROM GUN STORES THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF GUNS STOLEN REPORTED
BY THE BUREAU OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO
AND FIREARMS.
IS FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
GUNS.
NOW THAT WAS STOLEN AND
IDENTIFIED BY A GROUP OF
ORGANIZED CRIME OF FOLKS WHO
WERE DOING THE SMASHING GRABS
PARTICULARLY THROUGHOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THEY WERE CAUGHT.
THEY WERE ARRESTED THEY WERE.
APPROPRIATELY.
DEALT WITH.
THE FOLLOWING YEAR THERE WERE A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
BURGLARIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUT OF SIX THOUSAND
DEALERS.
OVER A MILLION GUNS THE NUMBER
IS.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR THIS PAST YEAR
THE NUMBERS ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR TOTAL GUNS THAT HAVE
BEEN STOLEN OUT OF AGAIN.
OVER A MILLION GUNS SOLD AND
MULTIPLE MILLIONS IN INVENTORY.
THAT SHOULD TELL US THAT THE
DEALERS ARE DOING.
AN INORDINATELY GOOD JOB OF
PROTECTING THEIR THEIR INVENTORY.
BY WHATEVER MEANS THEY HAVE
CHOSEN.
THEY'RE DOING A REALLY GOOD JOB
WE'RE TALKING A NUMBER THAT IS
POINT ZERO ZERO ZERO ZERO AND A
NUMBER.
OF THE GUNS ARE STILL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM GUN
DEALERS OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
BECAUSE THE DEALERS ARE DOINGA
GREAT JOB THE SENATOR DID A
GREAT JOB I THINK IN IN
ELEVATING THE ISSUE.
LETTING PEOPLE KNOW THE PEOPLE
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION THE AND
AND AND THAT WAS THAT WAS OF A
GOOD THING BUT THIS DOES NOT
NEED A GOVERNMENT SOLUTION.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO
GET TO PERFECTION AND THE
DEALERS ARE.
AS CLOSE TO PERFECTION AS YOU
CAN POSSIBLY GET.
JUST BY WHAT THEY ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW.
AND IN THIS CASE.
WORKING WITH THE OJWORKING WITH
THE A TF I THINK THEY WILL THEY
WILL CONTINUE DO A VERY GOOD JOB
FOR THESE REASONS IN THE REASONS
STATED BY MY MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
SEE EUROPEAN GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE OPEN FOR QUESTIONS AND
REFERENCES IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
THE SHEETS FROM THEA TF.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR QUIRK BAR QUE HAN
COMMA DOVE.
THE STE [inaudible]
AND WICKS.
YOU FIRST MR QUIRK PURE -- FIRST
OF ALL YOUR NUMBERS -- FOR
TWENTY SIXTEEN I HAVE A LETTER
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL FROM
GIFFORD'S LAWCENTER.
THE CHOSEN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH SPECIFIC
INCIDENTS THAT OVER TWO HUNDRED
GUNS WERE STOLEN WITCHES.
BELIEVE LARGER THAN THE NUMBER
YOU'VE GIVEN US AND AGAIN THIS
IS JUST SPECIFIC INCIDENTS I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE ALL
OR PART -- SO MISS CENTER HILL --
DO YOU HAVE NUMBERS FOR ANY OF
THOSE YEARS I DO NOT I MEAN I'D
THE NUMBERS I HAVE WE'LL GO BACK
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN
BUT I I FROM TWENTY THIRTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN WE AT THIRTEEN HUNDRED
GUNS WERE STOLEN IN THAT PERIOD
OF TIME BUT TO ME I I DON'T.
KNOW THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
NUMBER OF THE GUNS IT'S PROBABLY
MORE IMPORTANT IS.
THEY ARE STILL AND WHETHER IT'S
ONE OR HUNDRED OR TWENTY FIVE OR
WHATEVER THE COST THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF ADDING.
THE SECURITY IS TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT WAS RAISED AT THE
EXCESSIVE COST IN ONE CASE AND
ONE OPTION THEY COULD JUST
INSTALL SECURITY FILM OVER THERE.
GLASS DISPLAY CASES TODAY.
I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS DO YOU
HAVE.
SO AT I DO WE DO IT THE NUMBERS
IF OKAY CAN YOU GIVE ME THOSE
NUMBERS.
I GREW YEAH.
I KNOW HE TALKED ABOUT THE
NUMBERS -- YOU KNOW ONE GUN
KILLED MY DAUGHTER I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M SORRY ANYONE IS TOO
MUCH JUST THAT SO -- FOR TWENTY
SIXTEEN I HAVE UP THERE ARE NINE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
FIREARMS REPORTED STOLEN BY
AFL'S -- OF THE SEVEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT WERE
STOLEN TERM TERM BURGLARIES.
WHEREBY THERE WAS AN OFF
UNLAWFUL ENTRY TO COMMIT A THEFT.
AT GUN STORES OR YEAH AT AFFECT
THE HOUSE ALL RIGHT SO THE
NUMBERS THAT WE WERE GIVEN.
OUR ARE IN DISPUTE I TEND TO
BELIEVE -- THE BRADY CAMPAIGNS
NUMBERS BECAUSE I'VE HEARD OTHER
BAD NUMBERS FROM YOU BEFORE I'M
SORRY -- SECOND -- SO ONE OF THE
OPTIONS IS TO PUT IN A SAFE.
IF YOU PUT IN A SAFE IN YOUR
GROUND FLOOR.
I DO AND UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS.
THAT -- THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT
SOMEBODY JUST.
YOU KNOW BARRELING INTO THE
STORE ANYWAY BUT AS I READ THE
BILL YOU WOULD REQUIRE BOLLARDS
PERHAPS A ROLL DOWN STEEL DOOR.
AND I AM HEARING THE CONCERN
ABOUT THAT PERHAPS NOT
PARTICULARLY THE ROLL DOWN STEEL
DOOR I CAN IMAGINE A LOCALITY
JUST NOT WANTING THAT HAPPENED.
A COULD YOU ARE.
SAY SOME MORE ABOUT THAT -- BE
HAPPY TO THE YOUS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK OF THERE ARE.
EIGHT OPTIONS THAT SOMEONE CAN
CHOOSE FROM TO SECURE THEIR
WEAPONS IN THOSE STORES ONE OF
THEM IS TO BLOCK THE WEAPONS IN
THE STATE -- OKAY THE OTHER IS
LOCKING IN THE SAFE LOCK THE
MINUTE YOU HAVE THERE IN A SAFE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING
ELSE OKAY FINE.
AGAIN THIS WAS NOT WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION.
AND I TEND TO TRUST THE
AUTHORITIES BILLS I'M GONNA MOVE
THE BELL.
THE CAT IS A FEW [inaudible]
I'M.
SO I WOULD JUST.
YOU KNOW I'M A PRINCE WILL CALL
OFF THEIR THIS BILL SO OBVIOUSLY
I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT BUT I JUST
WANTED TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE.
BY SENATOR HILL THAT ONE GUN IS
TOO MANY HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY WHATEVER THE
NUMBER IS IT TAKES ONE TO TAKE A
LIFE AND SO.
YOU KNOW.
AS I READ THE BILL THERE ARE A
LOT OF OPTIONS AS TO HOW TO
SECURE IT BUT IF YOU HAVE A CLUE
THEIR OPTIONS THAT ARE WORKING
BECAUSE AGAIN THERE.
ABOUT A MILLION GUNS YOU SAID
SOLD A YEAR THREE MILLION OVER
THREE MILLION -- A YEAR AND A
LOT MORE THE MAJORITY DOES NOT
BEING SOLD SO THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS THAT ARE WORKING I'M
SURE SENATOR HILL WILL BE OPEN
TO OTHER OPTIONS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE.
BUT THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR GUNS EVEN
IF WE ASSUME THE LOW END IS TOO
MANY.
AND THAT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA SAFE AND
THAT MEANS ENSURING THAT THESE
FIREARMS AREN'T.
STOLEN AND USED IN THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME SO
[inaudible]
HI.
HELLO GOOD OF THANK YOU I'M SO I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS WHAT
ARE THE PENALTIES FOR NON
COMPLIANCE.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ADDRESS.
THEY LOSE THEIR PROBABLY FOR THE
FEET. THREE EIGHT THE LICENSE IS
SUBJECT TO FORFEITURE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT GOES TO THE
LICENSE FORFEITURE OF THE NOT --
I DIDN'T WITH JOHN CAN WE
RESPOND.
IF THE IF YOU TYPICALLY BE
VIOLATE ANY OF THE LAWS
GOVERNING THE OPERATION OF THE
BUSINESS IT'S THE LOSS OF YOUR
LICENSE AND BUSINESS.
SO CAN YOU SAY THAT AGAIN.
TYPICALLY IF YOU'RE INVOLVED IN
ANY VIOLATIONS OF THE LAWS
GOVERNED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WITH THE OPERATION OF
YOUR GUN DEALERSHIP.
IT'S THE LOSS OF YOUR LICENSE
AND YOUR ABILITY TO SELL
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION.
OKAY I DIDN'T SEE THAT LANGUAGE
IN HERE WHICH WAS WHY I WAS
ASKING FOR CLARIFICATION.
SO -- THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
IS IF YOU COULD JUST SORT OF RE
CLARIFY FOR ME -- THE DEFINITION
OF STORE A RETAILER OF LICENSE
DEALER AND THE REASON WHY I
ASKED THAT QUESTION IS BECAUSE
IN AN ADJACENT DISTRICT JUST A
MONTH AGO -- IN BEL AIR THERE
WAS A GENTLEMAN SOMEONE WHO WAS
I GUESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MAN WAS
DOING HE HAD OVER A THOUSAND
GUNS.
IN THIS HOME IN BEL AIR.
NOT A SQUEAK OR P..
ABOUT THE INJUSTICE A BE NOT
CHARGED.
OKAY ON BAIL FOR FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
I COULD GET INTO A WHOLE OTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
BIAS.
IN THAT BUT I'M NOT GONNA SAVE
THAT FOR ANOTHER BILL -- BUT I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO GET SOME
CLARIFICATION ABOUT YOU KNOW WHO.
WOULD REALLY BE IMPACTED IN
TERMS OF BEING A LICENSED DEALER
BECAUSE SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT HE
WAS NOT AND THEN I WOULD
CERTAINLY NOT WANT THAT PERSON.
TO BE EXEMPT FROM THIS WHICH WAS
MY PREVIOUS QUESTION ABOUT NON
COMPLIANCE AND PENALTIES BECAUSE
THAT PERSON SHOULD BE CHARGED
AND SHOULD BE GIVEN PENALTIES
AND THAT HASN'T HAPPENED.
WHAT?
IF THIS THIS WOULD APPLY ONLY TO
RETAIL DEAL RETAIL.
DEALERS AND THOSE WHO SELL AT
RETAIL FIREARMS AND IN THE
GETTING BACK TO YOUR OTHER
QUESTION JUST.
TO THIS DOES NOT ADD ANY
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES.
IN TERMS OF THIS THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE EXISTING LAW
AND IS CORRECTED IN A FIVE APPLY
TO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HE'S
SELLING GUNS OUT OF THE HOME
HE'S NOT.
YES AS WAS THE NFL.
I YOU THERE'S NO NO LIMIT ON THE
NUMBER OF GUNS THE INDIVIDUAL
CAN ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT THERE
ARE SAFE STORAGE LAWS IRAQ --
BUT IF HE WAS WASN'T AN FFL -- I
DON'T THINK HE WAS BREAKING THE
LAW IN TERMS OF HAVING A LOT OF
POSSESSING LOVE GUNS NOW HOW WE
GOT THE GUNS HE PROBABLY WAS AND
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE BUT SOMEONE
POSSESSING ON THANK YOU I WASN'T
AWARE THAT HE WAS RE SELLING
THEM IN.
AT RETAIL.
A TIME TO LEAVE.
THE DEEP.
TYLER.
HE WAS CHAIRMAN AYE AYES HAVE A
GUN.
I GUESS A A AND AND OBSERVATION
IN A QUESTIONS SOME.
OF THE THE BILL BEFORE US IS
SEEKING -- TO LIMIT GUN THAT
GUNS THAT CAN BE STOLEN -- FOR
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES.
DO WE KNOW WHAT A JOB.
THEN I HEARD DO YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY ANYTHING -- IN OUR
PENAL CODE THAT.
PUNISH THOSE THAT ACTUALLY GO TO
EIGHTY A GUN STORE AN STEAL GUNS.
IS THERE SOMETHING IN THE PEORIA
IT WITHOUT ITS OWN IN THE IN THE
VEHICLE.
IT'S A IT WOULD BE TH.
TH FIFTH AFTER THAT BEARD THE
BURGLARY OR SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE.
OF LAWS AGAINST THAT YES.
HAVE WE THOUGHT ABOUT --
DISCOURAGING.
PEOPLE FROM STEALING GUNS MORE
THAN JUST A KIND OF LIKE A PETTY
THREAT FOR THE I DON'T KNOW THAT
MAYBE A GOOD BILL BECAUSE I MEAN
I'M.
I'M I'M TRYING TO THINK OF IT
THE WHOLE POINT IS TO DISCOURAGE
PEOPLE FROM.
FROM STEALING GUNS -- SHOULD THE
THE BURDEN B. E. VALLEY.
DISTRIBUTED AMONGST GUN STORES
OWNER AND CRIMINALS I DON'T
THINK THAT IF IF THAT'S A
QUESTION HAVE BEEN ANSWERED I
DON'T THINK IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE THE GUN
STORE OWNER. TO TO DEIDE WHAT
PUNISHMENT SOMEONE SHOULD GET
BUT IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
A GUN STORE OWNER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE GUNS THAT THEY HAVE AND
THE WEAPONS THAT THEY HAVE ARE
PROTECTED FROM PEOPLE.
FROM STEALING THEM AND FROM
USING THEM -- AND GETTING THEIR
BASICALLY CONTROL OF THOSE
WEAPONS THE SECURITY OF THOSE
WEAPONS IS BECAUSE OF THE AFFECT
OF WITH THOSE WEAPONS CAN CAN DO.
IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE GUN
STORE AND WE ARE PROVIDING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THOSE OPTIONS
FOR THOSE GUN STORE OWNERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE.
WEAPONS ARE SECURE ARE SAFE OF
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE.
THE SECURITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN COME AND AND THAT MAKE
WHATEVER A REST AND ALLOW THAT
PERSON TO GO THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO -- I
MEAN THIS IS A TOOL.
TO REALLY HELP THE GUN STORE
OWNER PROTECT THEIR WEAPONS FROM
THE POSSIBLE LIABILITY THAT
COULD COME FROM THE LOSS OF
THOSE BY THEM NOT ACTING
RESPONSIBLY.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
AND IT ACTUALLY.
A COURT GENTLY IN THE GROVE BILL
ACTUALLY STATES THAT GRANT THAT
INVOLVES.
THE DEATH OF A PIRATE IS
PUNISHABLE BY IMPRISONMENT IN
STATE PRISON FOR SIXTEEN MONTHS
DO YOU TWO YEARS OR THREE YEARS
SO WE ALREADY HAVE.
PUNISHMENT FOR STEALING FIREARMS
AND IF YOU WANT SEE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE IT WOULD BE AN SENATOR
GROWTH.
ANALYSIS.
YES MISS WICKS.
SO -- THE OPPOSITION I THINK
STATED GOING BACK TO THE NUMBERS
FOREIGN SEVENTY NINE IN ONE YEAR
ONE SEVENTY FOUR AND ONE YEAR
AND THEN.
ONE FORTY FOUR SO THAT'S IF I DO
MY MATH RIGHT THAT'S SEVEN
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN GUNS STONE
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS.
OVER FIVE OR SIX MILLION GUNS IN
INVENTORY IN THESE DEALERS YES.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE NUMBER
TO BRAG ABOUT.
AND THAT'S NUMBER TO BE ASHAMED
OF AND IN MY OPINION THAT'S NINE
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN GUNS
TOO MANY THAT ARE OUT ON ON THE
STREETS PRESUMABLY NOT BY PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO USE THEM FOR
HUNTING -- AND TO YOUR POINT.
ONE GUN KILLED YOUR DAUGHTER
RIGHT -- AND I ALSO DON'T THINK
THAT THIS LAW IS GONNA CAUSE
UNDUE CONFUSION AND CHAOS AS
MENTIONED IT SEEMS PRETTY
STRAIGHT FORWARD TO ME THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP A GUN SAFE -- I'LL
BE VOTING FOR THE BILL WOULD
LIKE TO CALL AUTHORS WELL -- NO
MORE QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE
CENTER I I JUST I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
DISCUSSION TODAY IT'S HELPFUL TO
ME AND ND I THINK IT WAS --
GREAT AND AND I APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD
CONVERSATIONS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE.
THIS CONVERSATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU CHAIRS RECOMMENDED
I VOTE.
ON SB TWO TWENTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BAR QUE HAN BAR CAN I
DEEP.
DEEP NO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS.
WICKS I THE BILL PASSES THANK
YOU.
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
PRESENT ACR NINETY ONE SECOND.
SECOND CHANCES AND NOT WHEN IT.
THANK.
SENATOR BREAUX FOR ALLOWING ME
TO GO NEXT -- SECOND.
VERY LIKE WILL BE USING -- BUT
YEAH [inaudible]
A GOOD.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF ACR NINETY ONE RECOGNIZES
JUNE NINETEENTH AT SECOND
CHANCES MONTH IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS HAVING A
CRIMINAL RECORD HAS ADDED
BARRIERS TO SECURING HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT.
AND PARTICIPATING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THIS OFTEN
RESULTS IN MISS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES LEADING TO LOS
CHANCES OF A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEM.
AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH
OVERCROWDED PRISONS AND ONE IN
FOR CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING
INCARCERATION THIS TIME WE MOVE
AWAY FROM A PUNISHMENT FOCUS
SYSTEM AND INSTEAD TOWARDS ONE
CENTERED ON EFFECTIVE
REHABILITATION.
ACR NINETY ONE HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF EXISTING
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND HELPING
TO SUCCESSFUL REENTRY UP
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND
GIVING THEM A SECOND CHANCE HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY THAT
LITTLE. FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR -- GOOD
MORNING.
MY NAME IS A LITTLE AND I AM A
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE.
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ACR NINETY ONE DESIGNATING JUNE.
TWENTY NINETEEN A SECOND CHANCES
Là.
I AM ALSO A SURVIVOR OF
AMERICA'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND I COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF.
OF THE ESTIMATED EIGHT MILLION
RESIDENTS CURRENTLY LIVING WITH
A CRIMINAL CONVICTION AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO THE OVER HALF A
MILLION WOMEN [inaudible]
AND MEN.
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS AND JAILS
AND WHO ON PROBATION AND PAROLE
OR SOME FORM OF ELECTRONIC
MONITORING?
RIGHT -- SAID THIS CAPITAL.
WE HAVE ERECTED A SEVENTY FOOT
BY TWENTY FOOT WALL. TO SHED
LIGHT ON THE OVER. FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND LEGAL BARRIERS.
THAT PREVENT CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA.
FROM LIVING FOR AND PRODUCTIVE
LIVES.
THESE RESTRICTIONS PREVENT
NORMAL EVERYDAY PEOPLE.
FROM ACCESSING MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT THOSE OF US IN THIS
ROOM TAKE FOR GRANTED
[inaudible]
SUCH AS SECURING HOUSING.
EMPLOYMENT.
OR EVEN BEING ABLE TO CHAPERONE.
OUR CHILD'S FIELD TRIP.
WITHOUT QUESTION [inaudible]
OR EMBARRASSMENT.
THE WALL THAT IS THE RECORD HOW
SAD IS A LIVING MONUMENT THAT
BEGS THE QUESTION.
HOW LONG DO I HAVE TO SUFFER?
HOW LONG DOES MY FAMILY HAVE TO
SUFFER?
HOW LONG DOES MY COMMUNITY HAVE
TO SUFFER?
WHILE I WHERE THE INVISIBLE
CHAINS.
OF SOCIAL ISOLATION.
AND DEATH.
HAVING PAID MY DEBT TO SOCIETY.
AT WHAT POINT CAN WE AGREE.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE OVER.
WELL I AM HONORED TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY. FOR SOMETHING
AS IMPORTANT AS SECOND CHANCES
MONTH.
AT SOME POINT.
WE ALL HAVE TO SAY TIME DONE.
OKAY IT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH IN
SUPPORT.
I GUESS WE DO PLEASE NAY
REORGANIZATION.
NAME AN ORGANIZATIONAL IN PLACE
JESSICA GUNDERSEN OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAURICE OF LOTUS COMMUTERS GOES --
STRONG SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA COLORADO CALIFORNIA
SAFETY AND JUSTICE NEWMAN
SOPHOMORE.
MEARA DANDO COMMUNITIES IN
SCHOOLS I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
A MILITARIST COMMITTEES IN
SCHOOL STRONG SUPPORT.
EVEN A SECOND ON MY NAY
REPRESENT A HOME IS RUNNING THE
SALLY ARE YOU ARE.
OF STABLE JUNE FOR SECOND ABOUT
ON IT.
MOMENT DOES A COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BRETT THE CORDOVA
FROM COMMUNITY IN SCHOOLS AND
I'M A STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS RUNNING A BIAS IN A
FROM COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND I
SUPPORT STRONGLY SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE VASQUEZ FROM HOMELESS
ANIMALS AND I FROM THE SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JORGE LUIS AND FROM
COMMITTEES IN SCHOOLS AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS I'M I MEAN ALREADY
AND I'M REPRESENTING HOMIES ONLY
THOSE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE.
ME NUMBER SEVENTEEN ALLEN WE'LL
SEE IF SOME WITH BECKETT THE
MAGNIFICENT DONE THOUGH --
HOMELESS TO NEEDLES IS ALMOST
MANY NON IBM.
MY NAME IS ALREADY IN THE LIMITS
AND I AM ALSO HERE SUPPORTING
PROMISED US.
IF PLAY A KEY DEMAND BY THAT ON
THE TAPE THE CASE THAT THEY SAY.
AS THE LATE AND I'M HERE TO
PETITION THAT THIS -- Là PASSES
THIS BILL PASSES.
THANK YOU GAMBLE SAID THAT A
MIDDLE MAN TIME IS DONE.
WHEN I STARTED IN THE NUMBER
THROUGH THE CHECK CALL?
BANGOR THAT ARE GOING TO FEEL
HOMEY SWEENEY THEY'LL SEE THEM
UP WE AND THEN ONLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANY
CHECK ON I'M HERE WITH HOME USER
NEEDLES AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE LAW THE THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SIMON
I'M FROM ISRAEL SINGLE
SUPPORTERS.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN DEANGELO I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SEX WORKERS OUTREACH PROJECT
SACRAMENTO AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WHEN I STARTED THIS I MEAN
NUMBER IS ONE SIX ON SALE
ALARMING GO THAT ORGAN SYSTEM
HOME IS ON THE LOW EVEN WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND MAYBE THAT?
HI MY NAME IS CONCEPTS IN SALIVA
I'M HERE REPRESENTING COMING
THROUGH NEEDLES AND I SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE.
HI MY NAME IS BIANCA RAMOS AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
OUT AND I'M FROM COMMUNITIES IN
SCHOOLS SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
MY NAME IS PEARL CALLAHAN AND
I'M WITH THE SEX WORKERS
OUTREACH PROJECT AND I'M AND
SORRY STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MY
JEALOUSY VAN COMMUNITIES IN
SCHOOLS U. S. C. AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SUSAN SUSPECT I'M
FROM SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FROM
COMMUNITIES IN SCHOOL AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH FOR THE
FLORIDA FROM COMMUNITY SINCE
SCHOOL DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S MAKAYLA
JENKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LEVELS ADVOCACY GROUP AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU CLOSER THANK YOU --
AND EXPECT THE FBI VOTE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE MOTIONS SECOND
OKAY FAIRLY WE DO SO COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
ON ACR NINETY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO BE ADOPTED JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE.
POWER QUE HAN BAR QUE HAN I DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE F..
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK HI QUIRK I
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE AYE WICKS.
WICKS I GRADUATION SHOULD PASS
THANK YOU
.
OKAY BUT THE SHE'S NEXT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY MISTER GROSS SENATOR GROWTH --
SENATE BILL TWO TO FOUR ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE MOVE THE BELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR MOVING THE
BILL ON SECOND THE MOTION --
I'LL KEEP MY REMARKS BRIEF BASED
ON THAT AND I JUST THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL.
TO DO FOR IS VERY VITAL TO THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES IT TâM.
HELPS US PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
FRESNO KINGS MADERA MERCED
MONTEREY SAN BENITO SANTA
BARBARA SANTA CRUZ SAN JOAQUIN
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
STANISLAUS COUNTIES.
AND IT'S VERY GOOD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY THAT WE
BROUGHT IT THIS MORNING AS SAYS
SENATOR -- SKEWS ME AS SHERIFF
MIKE BOUDREAUX FROM TULARE
COUNTY AND AND WHO IS A LOCAL
FARMER HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
DAN VASSAR AND I'M A LITTLE OFF
I SHEEP AND CATTLE RANCHER FROM
THE DIXON AREA -- I AM HAVE BEEN
A VICTIM OF ROLE CRIME IT IS
AFFECTED ME GREATLY -- ON A
EARLY MORNING GOING TO MY IT IS
GRADUATION.
OF MY A QUAD WAS STOLEN.
AND IT REALLY AFFECTED MY LIFE --
BECAUSE NOW I LOOK OVER MY
SHOULDER ALL THE TIME.
A WONDERING WHEN THE NEXT
PERSON'S GONNA COME INTO THE
RANCH AND STEAL SOMETHING WAY --
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I CREATED
YEAH I HAVE GOTTEN SECURITY
SYSTEMS -- TO HELP ME THAT MY
NEIGHBORS HAVE BEEN PLAGUED WITH
OF ROLE CRIME WITH THEIR THEIR
PRODUCTS.
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS MINE WAS
JUST A QUORUM.
BUT THERE'S A VENN TRUCKLOADS.
OF AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS IN BIG
IMPLEMENTS WHICH REALLY AFFECT
THEIR BOTTOM LINE.
I AM IN SUPER SUPPORT OF THIS AT
OF SB -- TWO TWENTY FOUR SIMPLY
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO CSUS CIGARETTE
GATE AGRICULTURAL THEFT AND OF
PROVIDE FUNDING INTO CREATING
FOR TASK FORCE US SO WE CAN
GATHER DATA ON AGRICULTURAL
THEFT.
AND BEING ABLE TO MITIGATE SOME
OF THE THE PRODUCT OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT EXIST.
AGAIN I AM IN AWE -- VERY HIGH
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND NOT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKE -- DRAWN THE SHERIFF OF
TULARE COUNTY -- WE'RE PRETTY
MUCH IN THE CENTER OF CALIFORNIA
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
PREDOMINANTLY AGRICULTURAL BASED --
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY RULE CRIME
PREVENTION TASK FORCE WAS
CREATED -- ENDED IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE MANY OTHER COUNTIES
CAME ABOARD THE TULARE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE WAS THE VERY
FIRST AGRICULTURAL CRIMES UNIT.
NGUYEN IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
MANY OTHER COUNTIES CAME ABOARD
INCLUDING FRESNO KINGS KERN
MADERA MERCED SAN JOAQUIN
STANISLAUS COUNTIES.
S YEARS PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE THE IMPORTANCE OF
AGRICULTURE RELATED CRIME
INVESTIGATIONS BECAME ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR -- IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
MONTEREY SAN BENITO SANTA
BARBARA SANTA CRUZ AND SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY ALL INCORPORATED
AGRICULTURAL UNITS AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE CRIMES --
PROGRAM.
THE IMPORTANCE I GUESS WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE BRINGING FORWARD
TODAY IS THAT WE SEE.
MUCH AS OUR VICTIM HERE MANY OF
THOSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS STORY IS NOT
UNFAMILIAR TO ME.
BUT WE ALSO SEE HIGH LEVEL
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
IMPACT OUR ECONOMY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SHE MENTIONS A QUAD I CAN TELL
YOU THAT MY AGENCY IS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED NOW AND IN YEARS PAST
OF HALF A MILLION DOLLAR LOADS
OF PISTACHIOS ALMONDS WALNUTS.
AND OTHER -- COMMODITIES THROUGH
THE STATE THAT ARE STOLEN --
THIS DATA DRIVEN BASED.
ALLOWING -- FOR US TO MONITOR
AND KEEP TRACK OF DATA IN
EFFORTS TO REDUCE THOSE LEVELS
OF CRIMES IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- SO I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU ANY OF
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF THE CALL.
VERY GOOD STATE TELEVISION WITH
A CALIFORNIA FIRM HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VALERIE NORTH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
IF THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE CALIFORNIANS
CORSO'S ALONE WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYWAY THIS IS NOT POSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SO.
SENATOR GROVE AS I READ THIS
BILL -- AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
UP.
THERE'S NO CHANGE IN HOW THIS IS
TREATED AS A CRIME IT'S MORE OF
IN THE COUNTY MECHANISM SO THAT
YOU CAN KEEP TRACK.
OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THESE
RURAL AREAS IS THAT CORRECT IT
IS AND IT ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO COMMUNICATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OTHER AREAS IN
ORDER TO TRACK CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
THAT GOES FROM ONE AREA TO ADD
TOGETHER -- LIKE THE CENTRAL
COAST REAL CRIMES DIVISION CAN
COMMUNICATE AND AND TRACK AND
THEY CAN THEY CAN ACTUALLY
DETERMINE PATTERNS OF
CRIMINALITY THEY GO FROM ONE
AREA TO THE OTHER WHICH ALLOWS
THEM TO BE ABLE -- TO AT WORK
BETTER TO APPREHEND INDIVIDUALS
THAT WOULD BE COMMITTING THESE
CRIMES.
NO WONDER I'M IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS CENTER YOU
MAY CLOSE IT IS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO LIAM.
FIRST AND SECOND LET'S GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE QUESTION.
SB TWO TWENTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HI LACKEY AYE BAR QUE HAN.
BAR QUE HAN I DEEP.
DEEP I CAN LONGER DUFF.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THE MEASURES
PASSED REGULATIONS.
OKAY SENATOR BATES.
SB.
TWO EIGHTY THREE I REMEMBER
TWELFTH [inaudible]
SO.
GOOD MORNING ODD.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO US
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY THREE
WHICH WILL HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNDERSTAND AND QUANTIFY IT
CAUSES BEHIND.
FATAL COLLISIONS ON EVERY JOB.
MAY CONTINUE YOU WANT ME TO DO I
CLOSE.
YOU KNOW THEY SAY DON'T TALK
BEYOND THE DEAL SO ANYWAY --
DISCRETION CENTER.
AS YOU KNOW MANY OF DRIVERS
INVOLVED IN ACCIDENTS THESE DAYS
ARE IMPAIRED DUE TO ALCOHOL AND
OR DRUG CONSUMPTION WELL LOCAL
CORONERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
ARE REQUIRED DETAILS TO CEASE
DRIVERS AND PASSENGERS FOR
ALCOHOL CONTENT.
BUT NOT FOR DRUG CONTENT SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE ORANGE
AND SEND IT SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
VOLUNTARY BEGUN TESTING FOR
DRUGS CONTENT.
AFTER FATAL COLLISIONS BAD IT'S
BELIEVE THAT IF WE DO THIS STATE
WIDE WILL HAVE A BETTER DATABASE --
ON WHICH TO MAKE -- GOOD POLICY
DECISIONS SB TWO EIGHTY THREE
WILL UPDATE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRING DRUG TESTING AFTER
FATAL COLLISIONS IN ADDITION TO
ALCOHOL TESTING.
REFLECTING MORE ACCURATELY THE
MODERN USE OF PRESCRIPTION A
RECREATIONAL DRUGS I IT WILL
REQUIRE TESTING IN CASES OF
DEATH -- THAT OCCUR WITHIN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OF THE COLLISION
INSTEAD OF JUST TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDES
MORE DATA ON THE ON THE FATAL
COLLISIONS I HAVE WITH ME TODAY.
I IN SUPPORT IS ARIANNA IDEA
ABOUT SUPERVISING FORENSIC
SCIENTISTS AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
CRIME LAB THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR I TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE DRUG
TESTING.
OKAY ARIANNA YOU CAN MAKE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING -- I AM
THE SUPERVISOR OF TOXICOLOGY AT
THE ORANGE COUNTY CRIME LAB AND
I WORKED THERE FOR ALMOST TWELVE
YEARS.
I'VE WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE
INCREASE IN DRUG PREVALENCE DUE
TO THE LEGALIZATION OF MARIJUANA.
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND THE
INCREASE -- IN PRESCRIPTION PILL
USAGE.
THIS BILL IS THE RESULT OF THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S OFFICE.
THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT GET TO MAKE A
DECISION.
ON WHETHER TO TEST FOR DRUGS IN
FATALLY INJURED DRIVERS AND MOST
ARE MAKING THE DECISION NOT.
TO THE CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE
EXISTING LAW FOR FATALLY INJURED
DRIVER TESTING HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED IN OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
AND CONTAINS OUTDATED
REQUIREMENTS WE BELIEVE IT'S
TIME TO UPDATE THE LAW TO MATCH
CURRENT DRUG TRENDS SO THAT WE
CAN APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED THE
RISK.
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPAIRED DRIVING.
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
HIGHWAY TRAFFIC ASSOCIATION.
IT SAYS FATALITY ANALYSIS
REPORTING SYSTEM ARE FARR'S FOR
SHORT.
REPORTED THAT DRUGS WERE PRESENT
IN 43% OF THE FATALLY INJURED
DRIVERS WITH A KNOWN TEST
RESULTS.
THIS WAS MORE FREQUENTLY THAN
ALCOHOL WAS PRESENT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PROVIDES
10% OF THE NATIONAL FATALLY
INJURED DRIVE DATA DRIVER DATA
RATHER TO FARCE.
CURRENTLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE ALCOHOL RESULTS.
THIS MEANS THAT THE DRUG IMPACT
ON DRIVING AND FATAL INJURIES IS
GROSSLY UNDERREPORTED.
NOT ONLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
NATION WIDE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY WE BEGAN
TESTING ALL DRIVERS FOR THE
PRESENCE OF DRUGS REGARDLESS OF
BLOOD ALCOHOL CONTENT IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND FROM
THAT DATA WE HAVE COLLECTED WE
FOUND THAT AT LEAST ONE DRUG IS
PRESENT IN 46%.
OF ALL DRIVERS TESTED IN OTHER
WORDS ONE IN EVERY TWO DRIVERS
ARRESTED FOR DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
IMPAIRING DRUG IN THEIR SYSTEM.
WHEN WE LOOK AT ORANGE COUNTY
DATA IT REGARDING FATALLY
INJURED DRIVERS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE SEE THAT 62% OF
TESTED SAMPLES?
ARE POSITIVE FOR AT LEAST ONE
SUBSTANCE EITHER DRUGS OR
ALCOHOL AND THIS IS A 6%
INCREASE FROM.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND A 12%
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE ONLY MANDATES TESTING
FOR ALCOHOL AS I MENTIONED WITH
THE SUGGESTION TO ALSO TEST FOR
BARBITURATES AMPHETAMINE
DERIVATIVES.
BASED ON THE DATA ORANGE COUNTY
HAS COLLECTED CANNABINOIDS ARE
THE MOST PREVALENT DRUG AND ARE
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS BEHIND
ALCOHOL.
AND CANNABINOIDS ARE FOLLOWED BY
METHAMPHETAMINE.
BENTO DAYS IT PEEN MEDICATION
SUCH AS THE ANNEX.
MORPHINE AND ALSO COCAINE.
ALL OF THESE DRUGS WHICH ARE
KNOWN TO CAUSE DRIVING
IMPAIRMENT AND INCREASED RISK
FOR TRAFFIC COLLISIONS -- ACROSS
REQUIRING PROPER TESTING WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION TO
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE PREVALENCE
OF THE DRUG ISSUE.
OF ALL OF THIS BILL UPDATE.
CURRENT VERBIAGE IN THE EXISTING
LAW TO TEST FOR THE MOST
PREVALENT DRUGS ENCOUNTERED IN
DRIVERS.
AND THIS CAN PROVIDE VALUABLE
INFORMATION TO LEGISLATORS WHO
CAN MAKE EVIDENCE BASED
DECISIONS ON HOW TO BEST PREVENT
TRAFFIC FATALITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LUCIA MUCH CHARM
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CRIME LAB
DIRECTORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DAN YOUR TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE -- WERE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL AND WE
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THE
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT ESTABLISHED
TESTING LEVELS THAT ESTABLISH
IMPAIRMENT FOR SOME OF THESE
DRUGS THAT WOULD BE COVERED.
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU COULD HAVE A
DRUG IN YOUR SYSTEM BUT IT YOU
COULD HAVE.
ACTUALLY HAD THE DRUG A FEW DAYS
BEFORE A FEW WEEKS BEFORE BUT
STILL TEST POSITIVE FOR IT.
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE -- PROPER DATA WHEN
WE'RE GOING INTO THESE THINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ROM THIS IS BAD SCIENCE.
ALL RIGHT FIRST OF ALL.
THIS IS BEEN DONE WELL IN EUROPE.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO FIRST IS
DETERMINE.
OF THOSE DRIVING.
WHAT PERCENTAGE?
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE AMPHETAMINES.
YOU MAY FIND.
THAT.
AND THIS WAS FOUND THAT IN
EUROPE.
THERE'S ALMOST A 100% RISK OF AN
ACCIDENT IF YOU HAVEN'T FEATHER
MEANS THEY DO THIS BY SAMPLING
THE DRIVER POPULATION.
AND THEN SAMPLING THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN ACCIDENTS AND NOT
JUST THOSE WHO HAPPEN TO DIE
[inaudible]
FURTHER.
IT'S VERY CLEAR TO ME YOU'RE
GOING AFTER.
MARIJUANA IN PARTICULAR
MARIJUANA CAN BE IN THE SYSTEM
FOR DAYS AFTER YOU SMOKE IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU HAVE
IMPAIRMENT.
FURTHER.
IT'S ALL MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE FOUND
WITH MARIJUANA -- OFTEN ALSO
FOUND.
WITH.
OTHER DRUGS PARTICULARLY ALCOHOL.
UNLESS YOU COULD SEPARATE ALL OF
THIS WHAT YOU'VE GOT IS
CORRELATION.
BUT THAT'S NOT CAUSATION THIS IS.
JUST A OPEN SEASON.
ON MARIJUANA THIS IS AN OPEN
SEASON ON DOING BAD SCIENCE I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL I WILL
BE VOTING NOW I'M SORRY THAT I'M
A LITTLE BIT EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
BUT I REALLY SEE THIS AS POOR
SCIENCE.
WHAT YOU REALLY NEED TO DO IS
WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN EUROPE FIND
OUT?
WHAT THE DRIVING POPULATION HAS
AND THEN WHAT THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN ACCIDENTS HALF NOT
NECESSARILY THOSE?
WHO HAVE DIED IN AN ACCIDENT WHO
MAY WELL HAVE BEEN HIT BY
SOMEBODY ELSE IT CETERA YOU'VE
GOT TO LOOK AT THE PEOPLE AT
FAULT?
AGAIN THIS LOOKS TO ME LIKE AN
ATTACK ON CANNABIS AND I CANNOT
ACCEPT THIS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SURE YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN -- SITES
THAT WOULD NOT WITHSTANDING OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF CORPUS CON
MAN SO I SEE THE BILL IS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
JUST GATHERING DATA.
HI IF NOT FOR POLICY REASONS FOR
EDUCATION I'M NOT SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COMBINATION
OF AUG BEING -- CANNABIS USER
AND THEN HAVING I'LL BURBAGE
WELL SIR OPIOIDS BECAUSE OF PAIN
WHATEVER OUR THAT COMBINATION IT
CAN BE LETHAL WHEN THEY STEP
BEHIND THE WHEEL IN MAINE THEY
MAY NOT FEEL IT BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS.
DON'T HAVE A LASTING ABOUT SO
WHEN I AM TO CALL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE BILL
THAT WAS MY THOUGHT -- BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT I'VE.
ACQUIRED OVER ON SEVERAL
SESSIONS HERE ALL LOOKING AT THE
OPIOID ISSUE SO I THOUGHT IT WAS
A GOOD START I THINK THE THINGS
THAT YOU HAVE MENTIONED
CERTAINLY SHOULD NOT BE ARE
ABANDONED IN TERMS OF THE COOL.
THE COLLECTION OF DATA AND
TAKING A LOOK AT WHETHER THERE'S
CAUSATIVE -- CAUSE OF THE FACT
OR IF IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS SO
CONSEQUENTIAL ODDS SO THOSE ARE
THE REASONS I THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE GOOD TO MOVE FORWARD I KNOW
LOSS VERY SIMILAR BILL IDEA TO
LEAVE THE ASSEMBLY IS ON HIS WAY
THE SENATE.
THAT'S ASKING FOR THE SAME THING
IT HAD UNANIMOUS SUPPORT HERE IT
HAD CHAU CERTAINLY MY BILLS HAD
UNAIMOUS SUPPORT ON THE OTHER
SIDE SO THERE'S MERIT IN IT BOB
THAT I DO TAKE YOUR CAUTIONARY
COMMENTS.
THAT LET'S MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
USED IN THE PROPER MANNER AND I
SEE THAT EDUCATION ALL CERTAINLY
A LAW ENFORCEMENT ANY ON
CERTAINLY ALL THE GENERAL PUBLIC
IS IMPORTANT.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUILDING.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE -- FIRST A
SECOND THIS CALL FOR THE
QUESTION.
ON SB TWO EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY LACKEY AYE BAR QUE HAN
BAR QUE HAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK
NO QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
WICKS.
WICKS NOT LOADING.
MISTER JOHN SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
OKAY YOU CAN.
YOU WERE MORE -- WHEN -- ME ONE
MORE VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT BILLS ON CALL WHEN YOU ONE
MORE VOTE.
I'M SORRY SIR.
YEAH THE BILL'S ONCOLOGY ONE
MORE VOTE.
SING MEMBERS STILL OKAY THANK
YOU
[inaudible]
I'M.
YEAH.
I WAS BOTHERING HIM [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
USING A SOME
.
IS THE WINNER [inaudible]
MISTER WINNER.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MAYBE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR HEARING THIS TODAY
I WANT TO THANK YOU -- AND ALL
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING US
WORKING WITH US AND SB.
TWO THIRTY THREE WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS -- AND I KNOW THAT WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IF THEREARE
PERHAPS TWO WEEKS TO THE WORDING
A WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THAT BUT WE DO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS OF THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US.
THANK YOU FOR EXCEPT IN I
GUARANTEE WE WILL WORK YEAH
COMMITTEE WILL WORK WITH TWO
GREAT THANK YOU -- SO OUR
COLLEAGUES -- SB TWO THIRTY
THREE IS.
VERY -- I BELIEVE COMMONSENSE A
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OF SEX WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA OF
THE BILL THOSE TWO THINGS FIRST
OF ALL IT -- CREATES --
INCENTIVES FOR SEX WORKERS TO
COME FORWARD TO REPORT VIOLENT
CRIME -- AS OPPOSED TO BEING
DISSUADED FROM REPORTING VIOLENT
CRIME FOR FEAR OF BEING
THEMSELVES ARRESTED FOR SEX WORK --
AND IT HELPS ENSURE THAT SEX
WORKERS HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
CARRY CONDOMS WITH THEM -- RIGHT
NOW. SIX WORKERS UGH UGH
FREQUENTLY DO NOT COME FORWARD
TO REPORT VIOLENT CRIME WHETHER
THEY ARE THE VICTIM OF A VIOLENT
CRIME OR THEY ARE WITNESSING A
VIOLENT CRIME -- BECAUSE THEY'RE
FEARFUL THAT THEY WILL BE
ARRESTED FOR A SEX WORK RELATED --
FENCES ARE WE OF THE SEX WORKERS
ARE SIGNIFICANT INCREASED RISK
OF BEING VICTIMIZED WHETHER IT'S
ASSAULT OR RAPE.
OR KIDNAPPING OR ROBBERY SO
FORTH -- AND WE ALSO KNOW --
THAT THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT FEAR
THAT THEY'LL BE ARRESTED IF THEY
COME FORWARD -- WHEN A SEX
WORKER DOES NOT COME FORWARD TO
REPORT OF VIOLENT CRIME -- DOT
PUTS US ALL AT RISK BECAUSE IT
MEANS OF SOMEONE WHO IS VIOLENT
REMAINS OUT ON THE STREETS SO
THE BILL WILL.
PROVIDE THAT OF A SEX WORKER IS
REPORTING A SPECIFIED LIST OF
VIOLENT.
CRIMES -- THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO BE ARRESTED FOR A SEX WORK
RELATED OFFENSES -- THE SECOND
PIECE OF THE BILL HAS TO DO WITH
POSSESSION OF CONDOMS --
UNFORTUNATELY THERE -- ARE STILL --
A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
THAT WILL USE CONDOM POSSESSION
OF CONDOMS IS PROBABLE EVIDENCE
OF PROBABLE CAUSE.
OF THAT SOMEONE HAS COMMITTED
SEX WORK AND CAN BE USED -- IN A
COURT CASE -- ABOUT OF COURSE
CREATES A HUGE INCENTIVE FOR SEX
WORKERS NOT TO CARRY CONDOMS
WITH THEM -- WE KNOW THE SEX
WORKERS ARE AT INCREASED RISK OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED.
INFECTIONS WHETHER HIV OR OTHER
INFECTIONS.
AND THE LAST THING WE SHOULD BE
DOING -- IS TO CREATE A BIG
INCENTIVE FOR THEM NOT TO CARRY
A CONDOMS WITH THEM SO THE BILL
OF RIGHTS THE CONDOMS ARE NOT
EVIDENCE OF SEX WORK WHETHER FOR
PROBABLE CAUSE -- OR IMPROVING --
A CASE -- IN COURT -- SO -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS -- BILL AND WITH ME
TODAY ARE PEARL CALLAHAN -- AS
WELL AS MINUTI KENDELL WITH THE
ACLU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MANY
SCAM DOMON ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SB TWO THREE THREE IS AN ACTING
BEST PRACTICES TO IMPROVE HEALTH
AND SAFETY FOR SEX WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SB TWO THREE THREE IS INSPIRED
IN PART BY A POLICY THAT WAS
ENACTED IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING ON
WHEN I WAS AT THE DEPARTMENT ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN STAFFING SAN
FRANCISCO'S ANTI HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE TASK
FORCE THAT PERSONS IN COMMERCIAL
SEX WHETHER BY CHOICE OR
CIRCUMSTANCE OR COERCION WERE
SUBJECT TO EXTREMELY HIGH LEVELS
OF VIOLENCE SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
ONE STUDY. 77% OF WOMEN IN THE
SEX TRADE HAD REPORTED BEING
RAPED AS ADULTS AND 49% REPORTED
PHYSICAL ASSAULT FROM CLIENTS OR
QUAINTON SAYS.
AND FOR ST BASED TRANS GENDER
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR SEX WORKERS --
THEY ARE PARTICULARLY AT RISK OF
VIOLENCE AND YET A SENATOR
WIENER HAS NOTED HAD NO DATE HAS
NOTED MANY SEX WORKERS ARE
RELUCTANT TO COME FORWARD AND
REPORT THEIR CRIMES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF
EXPERIENCES OF BEING
CRIMINALIZED.
AND THIS IS INCLUDES PERSONS
TRAFFICKED IN COMMERCIAL SACKS
WERE FROM TOLD BY THE PERSON WHO
TRAFFIC THEM THAT THEY'LL BE
ARRESTED IF THEY REACH OUT FOR
HELP.
AND SO -- SAN FRANCISCO ENACTED
ITS POLICY IN EARLY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND ALREADY THIS HAS
RESULTED IN THE PROSECUTION OF A
PERSON WHO VIOLENTLY KNIFED A
SEX WORKER.
AND THAT VICTIM WAS INITIALLY
TERRIFIED TO TELL POLICE WHO HAD
ATTACKED HER UNTIL SHE WAS
LITERALLY SHOWN A COPY OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S POLICY.
SO SB THREE THREE TWO THREE
THREE IS ESSENTIALLY CREATES A
WAY FOR SEX WORKERS TO COME
FORWARD AND SAY NEED -- TO IN
ADDITION IN IT -- NUMEROUS
GROUPS ARE SUPPORTING IT
INCLUDING THE LESS ANGELES AND
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND NANCY
O'MALLEY THE DA FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY HAD TO LEAVE BUT SHE
ASKED ME TO SAY THAT THEIR
OFFICES ALSO IN SUPPORT AND
SHOULD BE GETTING A LETTER IN
SOON.
THE OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
PROVISION OF SB TWO THREE THREE
DEALS WITH -- NOT PERMITTING
CONDOMS TO BE USED TO
CRIMINALIZE SEX WORKERS AND
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A VERY
CONTRADICTORY POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
DISTRIBUTE ENCOURAGE THE USE OF
CONDOMS AND IN MANY OF THOSE
SAME STRESSED ACTIONS.
POLICE ARE USING THOSE SAME
CONDOMS AS EVIDENCE TO ARREST
PEOPLE FOR SEX WORK WHICH
OBVIOUSLY CREATES A DISINCENTIVE
FOR GREAT SEX WORKERS TO CARRY
CONDOMS WHICH INCREASES RISKS OF
HIV SEXUALLY TRANCE.
HAD THE CONDOMS REMOVED FROM
THEM BY POLICE SO WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB TWO THREE THREE SEX
WORKERS SHOULD NOT BE
CRIMINALIZED REPORTING VIOLENCE
OR FOR CARRYING CONDOMS.
MY NAME IS PEARL CALLAHAN.
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE SEX
WORKERS OUTREACH PROJECT
SACRAMENTO.
I'VE BEEN A SEX WORKER FOR FORTY
YEARS.
I WAS TRAFFIC FOR TEN OF THOSE
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND FROM A
PRETTY ROUGH SECTION OF TOWN MY
FAMILY'S PORN FROM OAK PARK.
I'M FROM THE MY FATHER SINGLE
MAN WITH NINE KIDS RAISING US.
I FOUND MYSELF PREGNANT AT AGE.
SIXTEEN I DIDN'T HAVE ANYWHERE
TO GO I HAD NO MONEY.
I HAD A BOYFRIEND THAT WAS
THIRTY YEARS OLD THE TOLD ME
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT I'M GONNA
TAKE CARE OF YOU.
HE IS TAKING CARE OF ME WAS TO
PUT ME ON THE STREET.
AND WHEN HE PUT ME OUT THERE.
I WASN'T ALLOWED TO USE CONDOMS
HE WOULD NOT LET ME USE CONDOMS
TO PROTECT MYSELF.
BECAUSE HE SAID IF I GOT CAUGHT
WITH THEM I GO TO JAIL AND IF I
GO TO JAIL I CAN'T MAKE MONEY I
CAN'T SUPPORT MY SON
[inaudible]
SO.
THE VERY THING THAT WAS KEEPING.
THE PUBLIC SAVE MY COMMUNITY
SAVE ME SAFE I WASN'T ALLOWED TO
USE THEM.
AND THIS HAS TO STOP.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THEY
HAVE A PROGRAM.
IT'S CALL GETTING.
TO ZERO AND THEIR GOAL IS.
TO BY [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE NO NEW [inaudible]
HIV TRANSMISSIONS.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
[inaudible]
WITHOUT US.
IF I AM NOT SAFE THEN YOU'RE NOT
SAFE.
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THE PUBLIC KNOWS THAT.
WHEN I'M AFFECTED IT AFFECTS ALL
OF US?
AND SO SB THIRTY SB TWO THIRTY
THREE IS SO IMPORTANT. TO
PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC TO PUBLIC TO PROTECT
ME TO PROTECT MY COMMUNITY.
SO PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
THE BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT.
HELLO AMY WRITES A BACK WITH THE
EROTIC SERVICE PROVIDERS UNION
AND FOR THE SAFETY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MAXINE DUGAN OF THE EROTIC
SERVICE PROVIDERS LEGAL
EDUCATION RESEARCH PROJECT A
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
CAN YOU GOOD TERRORISM HAVE A
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND THE FREE
SPEECH COALITION BOTH IN SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAK A NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TOMAR TALK OUT WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
JAMES BIRCH.
WITH THE SAINT JAMES INFIRMARY
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS.
CHRISTEN DEANGELO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SEX WORKERS
OUTREACH PROJECT SACRAMENTO ALSO
CONSENSUAL SEX WORKER AND A
SURVIVOR OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT IN MY
ORGANIZATION AS AS WELL.
JIM LIMBURGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I NEED A ROGERS A CO YOU IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR TERM MEMBERS COURSE
AS A LOW.
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION REGRETTABLY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I THINK
WE HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS ARE
ONLY THE ONES THAT FOCUS ON THE
PROSECUTORIAL SIDE OBVIOUSLY TO
MY COLLEAGUES.
BUT I WOULD JUST NOTE WE WE
WOULD ARGUE THAT WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL -- DESPITE ITS GOOD
INTENTIONS CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVE -- FOR DRUG OFFENDERS
ARE PEOPLE ENGAGED IN
PROSTITUTION -- TO CLAIM THAT
THEY ARE VICTIMS OR WITNESSES TO
THE SPECIFIED CRIMES AS DEFINED
IN THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT.
THE BY REPORTING THIS VICTIM
HOOD OR HAVING WITNESSED ANOTHER
CRIME -- BY OPERATION OF THE
BILL ABSOLVES THAT PERSON FROM
THE ARREST FOR THE UNDERLYING
DRUG OFFENSE OR PROSTITUTION
OFFENSE -- I I THINK THE
PROPONENTS OF SAID IN
CONVERSATIONS THAT THE BAR TO
THAT OR WHAT WILL AMELIORATE
THAT IS THAT A PERSON WHO
FALSELY CLAIM SUCH COULD BE
SUBJECT TO PROSECUTION FOR A
FALSE REPORT.
BUT IT MAY NOT BE THE CASE THAT
IT'S NOT TRUE IT JUST MAY NOT BE
HAVE PROOF HAVE BEEN PROVEN AT
THE POINT SO.
IF A PERSON WHO'S ABOUT TO BE
ARRESTED FOR PROSTITUTION SAYS
I'M A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
PURSUANT TO THE OPERATIONS BILL
THAT'S IT THEY CANNOT BE
ARRESTED FOR THE PROSTITUTION.
AND AT THAT POINT THEN IF THERE
WERE ANY SORT OF RUBBER CAUTION
FOR FALSELY REPORTING THAT HE
WOULD HAVE TO BE AFTER THE FACT
THE YOU HAVE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SITUATION GOING ON
IN.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT PERSON WAS
INDEED A VICTIM SO AGAIN IT'S
IT'S IT'S MORE OF THE OPERATIONS
IN THE LOGISTICS OF THE BILL
THAT SAYS OKAY AT THIS POINT IN
THE PROCESS IF YOU SEE THESE
MAGIC WORDS.
YOU ARE IMMUNE FROM ARREST THERE
ARE OTHER POINTS IN THE PROCESS
WHERE VICTIMHOOD OR THE FACT
THAT.
THAT PERSON'S BEEN WITNESS TO
ONE OF THESE CRIMES CAN BE
CONSIDERED -- AND AGAIN THAT'S
MORE THE PRODUCT OR ROUND BUT
FROM THE SUREST PERSPECTIVE I
THINK TAKING AWAY INFORMATION --
FROM JUDGES JURIES PROSECUTORS
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION MAKE DECISIONS -- WITH
THE FULL WEIGHT OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND EVIDENCE IN
THE TO TALLY OF CIRCUMSTANCES
IMPORTANT.
AND AGAIN FOR THOSE REASONS WITH
ASPIN ABOUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES SIR GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS LAURIE
MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION.
WHO WE ARE -- REGRETFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL WHICH WOULD
AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS PROHIBIT
PROSECUTORS FROM USING CONDOMS
AS EVIDENCE OF PROSTITUTION
REGARDLESS OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF A PARTICULAR CASE.
THERE IS A STRONG PRESUMPTION IN
FAVOR OF THE ADMISSIBILITY OF
EVIDENCE IN OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
IN FACT WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADMISSIBILITY OF EVIDENCE IN A
CRIMINAL CASE THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION.
PROVIDES THAT ALL EVIDENCE IS
ADMISSIBLE EXCEPT BY A TWO
THIRDS VOTE OF THE LEGISLATURE.
SB TWO THIRTY THREE WOULD
LEGISLATIVELY PROHIBIT CONDOMS
FROM BEING USED AS EVIDENCE OF
PROSTITUTION.
LEWD ACTS IN PUBLIC LOITERING
WITH THE INTENT TO COMMIT
PROSTITUTION.
AND COMMITTING A PUBLIC NUISANCE
REGARDLESS OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
CONDOMS WOULD ALSO BE PROHIBITED
FROM BEING THE BASIS FOR
PROBABLE CAUSE TO ARREST FOR THE
SAME OFFENSE.
CDA A BELIEVES THAT AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHETHER OR NOT A
CONDOM IS EVIDENCE IT SHOULD BE
MADE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE COURTS AND THE DECISION
ON WHETHER OR NOT TO PROSECUTE
IS BEST LEFT TO INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OFFICES TO
MAKE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
AMPLE SAFEGUARDS BEFORE THE
POSSESSION OF CONDOMS CAN BE
INTRODUCED AS EVIDENCE.
THAT A CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
BEFORE SUCH EVIDENCE IS ADMITTED.
THE PROSECUTOR SHALL MAKE A
WRITTEN MOTION TO THE COURT AND
THE DEFENDANT STATING THAT THE
PROSECUTOR HAS AN OFFER OF PROOF
OF THE RELEVANCY.
OF THE POSSESSION BY THE
DEFENDANTS OF ONE OR MORE KHN.
THE WRITTEN MOTION SHALL BE
ACCOMPANIED ACCOMPANIED BY AN
AFFIDAVIT CONTAINING THE OFFER
OF PROOF AND SHALL BE FILED
UNDER SEAL.
AND ONLY AND SEALED BY THE COURT
WHO DETERMINES IF THE OFFER OF
PROOF IS SUFFICIENT TO ORDER
HEARING.
IF THE JUDGE DETERMINES THAT THE
OFFER OF PROOF IS SUFFICIENT A
HEARING IS HELD OUTSIDE THE
PRESENCE OF THE JURY WERE THE
OFFER OF PROOF CAN BE CHALLENGED
BY THE DEFENSE.
IF THE IF THE COURT FINDS AFTER
SUCH A HEARING THAT THE OFFER OF
PROOF IS RELEVANT AND NOT
INADMISSIBLE THE COURT MAY THEN
STATE WHAT EVIDENCE MAY ENTER
MAYBE INTRODUCED BY THE
PROSECUTOR.
THOSE ARE SIGNIFICANT
PROTECTIONS ALREADY IN LAW.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
LEGALIZE SEX WORK.
IT SHOULD INTRODUCE LEGISLATION
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT ENGAGE IN A
PUBLIC DEBATE.
ON THE ISSUE.
INSTEAD OF NIBBLING AROUND THE
EDGES OF THE ISSUE AND TELLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTORS
WHAT IS.
AND ISN'T EVIDENCE.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES IMMUNITY
FOR DRUG CRIMES IN PROSTITUTION.
TO ANYONE REPORTING SPECIFIED
CRIMES WHETHER OR NOT ANY
CORROBORATION OF THOSE
ALLEGATIONS EXIST AS MY
COLLEAGUES NOTED.
WELL CITY A. L. CDA WELL
RECOGNIZES AND APPRECIATES THE
STRUGGLES AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS OF THOSE ENGAGED IN SEX
WORK WE BELIEVE SB TWO THIRTY
THREE IS BAD POLICY.
AND ESTABLISHES A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MOVED WELL.
MISS WICKS -- THANK YOU LACKEY.
I JUST I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IN AND SHARING
YOUR STORY -- THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL I'LL BE
VOTING FOR TODAY AND I'D LIKE TO
CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
MR LACKEY.
YEAH.
I THINK THIS AS SOON SO VERY ON
NOTABLE THINGS TO CONSIDER WHAT
ONE OF MY CONCERNS WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD BY.
THE OPPOSITION ON THE
COOPERATION PIECE -- AND AND SEE
IT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT HAVE --
SEX WORKERS ARE ENGAGED.
AND WHATEVER THEY'RE DOING AND
THAT THEY WITNESS AS A
SIGNIFICANT CRIME THAT.
THEY DO NEED TO BE ABSOLVED FROM.
FROM THE RESPONSIBILITY IN PLACE
AND REST HOWEVER.
WE ALWAYS HAVE PRETENDERS RIGHT
WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF AND IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THE BILL OF
THE COOPERATE TO TO HAVE.
REQUIRES A CERTAIN DEGREE OF
COOPERATION THAT ARE THERE WAS
AN ACTUAL CRIME COMMITTED THAT
THE REPORTING.
THROUGH THE CHAIR ARM.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
QUESTION I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TWO THINGS
DISTINGUISH FIRST OF ALL OF THIS
IS NOT ABOUT -- IN TERMS OF THE
IMMUNITY FROM ARREST OUT THE
CONDOM PEACE BUT THE REPORTING A
CRIME PLEASE THIS IS NOT ABOUT
IMMUNITY A TRIAL WHERE.
YOU MIGHT TALK ABOUT NEEDING
COOPERATION BECAUSE YOU'RE IN
THE SETTING OF A TRIAL THIS IS
ABOUT A VERY QUICK DECISION THAT
A POLICE OFFICER MAKES -- SHOULD
I OR SHOULD I NOT ARREST THIS
PERSON SO ON TO MY EYES IN A
SCENARIO WHERE A SEX WORKER
APPROACH IS A POLICE OFFICER --
AND SAYS I WAS ON MY I WAS JUST
RATE ON AND OR I WAS JUST.
ROBBED -- OR MY THAT MY JOHN --
JUST BEAT THE HECK OUT OF ME.
I AND I THE THE OFFICER ON IT
THIS IS NOT SOME SORT OF
COURTROOM SETTING WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY WHAT'S THE
CORROBORATION RIGHT THERE MAKING
A DECISION RIGHT THEN AND THERE.
ON WHETHER TO ARREST AND I AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND WE'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED WITH THE BILL'S VERY
FOCUSED.
THAT THE ONLY CRIMES THAT YOU
REPORT THAT WOULD TRIGGER THIS
ARE.
ARE SERIOUS VIOLENT CRIMES LIKE
RAPE LIKE KIDNAPPING LIKE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND THE CRIMES.
THAT YOU FOR WHICH YOU ARE
IMMUNIZED HARASSED OR CRIMES
THAT I ARE NOT PARTICULARLY
SERIOUS POSSESSION OF DRUGS.
PROSTITUTION LOITERING BEING A
NEW SENSE OF THE THESE ARE NAY
SO WE WHEN YOU BALANCE -- WHAT
WHAT IS MORE IMPORTANT I MAKING
IT AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO REPORT THE MOST
HEINOUS CRIMES THAT ARE A THREAT
TO THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY?
OR POTENTIALLY IF SOMEONE DOES.
HE OUGHT NOT HAVING THEM BE
ARRESTED FOR LOITERING OR FOR
COMMITTING A NEW SENSE I THINK
WHEN YOU BALANCE THE RISK.
THE RISK OF A VIOLENT PERSON
BEING FREE ON THE STREET OR THE
RISK OF NOT ARRESTING SOMEONE
FOR ENGAGING IN LOITERING IT'S
NOT EVEN A CLOSE CALL I WOULD
RATHER WE ERR ON THE SIDE.
OF PROTECTING NOT JUST THE SEX
WORKERS BUT EVERYONE FROM A
VIOLENT PERSON ON THE STREET AND
AND SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
NEED.
FOR COOPERATION WHATEVER THAT
WOULD MEAN HERE -- I THINK THAT
WE STRUCK.
A GOOD BALANCE I UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE POINT OF SAYING BUT I THINK
THIS IS THE RIGHT BALANCE FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY HERE.
THIS WAS GONNA GET A THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU -- JUST MADE
THOSE COMMENTS BECAUSE I SEE IT
AS YOUR TRADING YOU KNOW A
MISDEMEANOR FOR A FELONY -- AND
WE WOULD MUCH RATHER BE FOCUSED
ON THOSE -- YOU KNOW FELONY --
CHARGES AND CONVICTIONS AND I
ALSO SORT OF AND I HEARD THE
OPPOSITION -- AND I I CERTAINLY
RESPECT WHAT YOU ALL ARE --
SAYING AND THAT YOU ARE HERE --
I ALSO THINK THOUGH IF YOU KNOW
THE EVIDENCE THAT THE
PROSECUTION IS WEIGHING ON IS
YOU KNOW HAVING A STACK OF
CONDOMS YOU KNOW IN YOUR PURSE
OR IN YOUR POCKET THEN.
THAT COULD BE A WEAK CASE MAY
NOT BE BUT IT COULD BE -- AND SO
I'M THANKFUL THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD I TOO WOULD ASK TO
BE A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND
I WILL BE SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENT.
MISTER WEINER YOU MAY CLOSE -- I
THANK YOU AND I DO -- I'VE EVERY
RESPECT CDA DO YOU WANT TO JUST
REITERATE THAT WE THE LOS
ANGELES CA THE SAN FRANCISCO DA
AND SOON TO BE THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DA THREE OF THE LARGEST.
STATE -- COUNTIES IN THE STATE
THREE OF THE COUNTIES -- THAT
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT POPULATIONS
SEX WORKERS THOSE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE ALL IN SUPPORT OF
WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND IT IS.
IN IN.
I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND BOTH
SHARES IN THE DA'S CONCERNED I
MEAN I'M I'M.
ONE IF YOU WERE TO TALK TO THE
AUTHOR.
OUT OF STOCKTON [inaudible]
ON A NEIL EXCHANGES THAT WAS
REALLY.
DIFFICULT FOR ME [inaudible] TO
TO STEPHEN HAD THAT BEEN HEARD
IN MY COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF
OBVIOUSLY GREATER GOOD BUT YOU
ALSO DON'T WANT TO LEGALIZE
PEOPLE.
HAVING TO BE ABLE TO SHOOT UP
BUT ONCE.
IT WAS EXPLAINED TO ME ABOUT THE
GREATER GOOD OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO -- EIGHT IT
SOFTENED ME AND GOT ME.
IF CLOSER TO ULTIMATELY
RECOMMEND IMPROVE NOT ONLY JUST
COMMITTEE AND IN VOTING FOR ON
THE FLOOR -- AND ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT IF SOMEONE IS DOING
SOMETHING ILLEGAL THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT THEIR HANDS
ARE TIED THAT THEY CAN'T GO
AHEAD AND AN ARREST SOMEONE IT --
PROSECUTE THEM OF THE PART THAT
I THINK REALLY HELPS AND WE MAY
NEED TO FURTHER EXPLAIN IS.
SALAS MORE PROACTIVE IT'S NOT
YOU GET BUSTED IN YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET OUT OF SOMETHING.
YOU.
YOU AS OF SEX FOR HER.
GO TO LAW ENFORCEMENT A REPORT A
CRIME.
SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT I DID
FOUR PEOPLE WERE IMMIGRANT.
THEY REPORT A CRIME.
BUT YOU DON'T ARREST HIM FOR NOT
BEING -- PART OF THIS COUNTRY OR
YOU DON'T HAVE THE ICE AGES COME
AND GET YOU BECAUSE A REPORTER
VERY HEINOUS CRIME YOU WANT TO
REPORT MURDER AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
AND SO WE WE PROVIDE AN
PROTECTIONS.
IT'S KIND OF FALLS INTO IN THE
SAME VEIN THAT DO YOU WANT TO
PROTECT PEOPLE.
AND SO I I GET WE TRY TO GO AND
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN YOU WILL
CONTINUE TALKS WITH.
WITH THE WITH OFFICE BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE I KNOW I
DON'T THINK I KNOW YOUR INTENT.
IS NOT.
TO BECAUSE THE MANY PROBLEMS IN
DOING DIRECTOR TO DATE A JOB TO
TO REDUCE -- THINGS AND WHATNOT
OBVIOUSLY THIS COMMITTEE IS NOT.
AT LEAST TODAY.
WE'RE NOT HAVING TO DISCUSSION
ABOUT LEGALIZING -- CERTAIN AXE
RIGHT NOW -- I GUESS IT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE BY GOOD
DEFINITELY THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO DAY.
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING HUMAN
BEINGS TODAY.
ANNOUNCER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
UNLESS BE TWO THIRTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
JONES SAWYER.
JOHN SO YOUR EYES LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BAR QUE HAN.
BAR CAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THE BILL PASSES BY
THE COLLEGE [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
I
THE
VOTER ADS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
LACKEY.
LACKEY I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I ITEM NUMBER ONE
HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWO HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER THREE LACKEY.
SB TWENTY TWO OCT.
LACKEY I WICKS WICKS I ITEM
NUMBER FOUR HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE HUSBAND
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER SIX HAS BEEN
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH ITEMNUMBER NINE
SB TWO TWENTY FOUR SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB TWO TWENTY
FOUR GROVE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I'D.
SB.
TWO THIRTY THREE ITEM NUMBER TEN
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB TWO EIGHTY
THREE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING LAST
RECONSIDERATION [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
BY -- RECONSIDERATION UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
AKON HAS BEEN GRANTED.
ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ON ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN IT HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB THREE
NINETY NINE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SB FIVE
FIFTIES.
BY FIFTY FOUR SEVEN HUSBAND
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN
OH ONE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
AND ON CONSENT MR SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I AND THEN I BROKE
[inaudible]
YES.
ON EVERYTHING YEAH. FOR WHICH
TIME [inaudible] NINE I WAS OUT
HE CAME IN AFTER A IN MY
BREAKING THE TIME [inaudible]
BATES -- HE FOR BATES NOT.
I LEFT WITH GROW I GOT THE I
DIDN'T VOTE ON GROVE.
YEAH WITH THIS ITEM.
ON TO TO OKAY.
ON ITEM NO NUMBER NINE SB TWO
TWENTY FOUR JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
THAT IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE